[MUSIC PLAYING]
GRAY: Good morning.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm Paul Gray, chairman of the
Institute's governing board,
and it is my privilege and
pleasure to welcome all of you
to this 1995 Technology Day.
Before I begin
the introductions,
however, there's a question
I want to put to all of you,
or at least to all of you
who were at Symphony Hall
last night.
Wasn't that an evening, huh?
[APPLAUSE]
We have displayed
here on the stage,
or we had a moment ago, the
photographs of Jay Stratton
and Jerry Wiesner.
And you will have noticed that
this Technology Day program is
dedicated to the memory of
Jay and Jerry, both of whom
passed away in this last
year, and both of whom
were deeply involved
throughout their lives
with MIT, and in
particular with that effort
that is the focus
of our activities
this morning, the Second
World War at this institution.
And it seemed appropriate
for the committee
to make that dedication.
The Technology Day
program this morning
focuses on World War II and MIT.
The Institute played important
roles in the war effort,
and it was profoundly
and irreversibly changed
by the war, as was the whole
fabric of American society.
In this morning's program,
50 years, give or take
a month or two, from
the end of the war,
we reflect on the
origins of that conflict,
on the Institute
during the war years,
and on the continuing
influence of the World War II
experience on society, on
this nation's universities,
and on this special place.
Our principal and keynote
speaker this morning
is a distinguished
biographer and historian
whose work has illuminated
the American political scene
in the 20th century.
Doris Kearns Goodwin earned her
PhD in government at Harvard,
where she was a
Woodrow Wilson fellow,
and where she served as
professor of government
for 10 years.
In the 1960s, she
served as assistant
to President Lyndon
Johnson, whom
she assisted in the
preparation of his memoirs.
In the last 18 years,
she has published
three important, highly
acclaimed big books, each
of which became a bestseller.
In 1976, Lyndon Johnson
and the American Dream.
In 1987, The Fitzgeralds
and the Kennedys.
And most recently, in
1994, No Ordinary Time--
Franklin and Eleanor Roosevelt,
the American Home Front
During World War II.
For this most
recent book, she was
awarded just a few months
ago the 1995 Pulitzer
Prize for history.
Dr. Goodwin appears frequently
in public affairs programs
on television, and
has made appearances
in documentaries for PBS
concerning LBJ, the Kennedy
family, FDR, and, as a
measure of her breadth,
Ken Burns' series on
the history of baseball.
[LAUGHTER]
Dr. Goodwin is
eminently qualified
to put World War
II in perspective
for us at the outset of
this morning's program.
Please join me in welcoming
Doris Kearns Goodwin to MIT.
[APPLAUSE]
GOODWIN: Thank you.
Let me say before I begin that
it has been my great privilege
in these last few months to have
two loves of mine come together
at the same time.
First, more obviously,
my love of baseball,
reflected in this 18-hour
history of baseball
that Ken Burns put
on the air where
he needed an irrational female
fan, so he kept showing me
over and over again, so that
when my book on Franklin
and Eleanor came out at the
same time, embarrassingly,
it took me more years to
write the book than it
took the war about which it
was written to be fought.
It did finally come
out at the same time,
but more people have
asked me about baseball
than about Franklin
and Eleanor as I've
wandered around the country.
However, these two loves
are not really as separate
as they might seem, for I
often root my love of history
to the day when my father
bought me my first big red score
book when I was
only six years old,
and taught me that mysterious
and wonderful art of keeping
score play by play,
inning by inning
while he was at work
during the day so
that, when he came
home at night,
I could record for him the
history of that day's Brooklyn
Dodgers game.
And when you're
only six or seven
and your father thinks you're
doing OK as an historian,
it's a great impetus
to do it later in life.
He made it even
more magical for me,
for he never told
me that all of this
was actually described in
the newspapers the next day.
So I thought, without
me, he would never
know what happened to our
beloved Brooklyn Dodgers.
But to the main story
at hand, it seems to me
that the story of the
homefront in World War II
is really the story of the
transformation of a nation,
a nation whose economy
in 1939 and 1940
was still paralyzed
in depression,
with 17% unemployment, a nation
in which only one out of four
Americans graduated
from high school,
one in 20 completed college, in
which the average worker earned
less than $1,000 a year and
the majority of citizens
lived in small towns stratified
along class and ethnic lines.
It is the story of an army
which, in 1940, stood only 18th
in the world, trailing
not only Germany, Britain,
and France, but also
Belgium, Spain, and Holland,
of a military establishment
that possessed only 400 combat
planes, a mere one-day supply
in the current European war,
and almost no modern
tanks, weapons, or guns.
And yet, following the fall of
Western Europe to Nazi Germany,
and then the Japanese
attack on Pearl Harbor,
Franklin Roosevelt was able to
mobilize the American people
to work together for a common
cause against a common enemy,
forging an unparalleled
partnership between government
and business, which provided
generous loans and incentives
to build new
factories to produce
the weapons and the planes and
the tanks, which stimulated
15 million Americans to
leave their hometowns
and to congregate where the
war plants were in the north
and in the west, so that
somehow, one year after Pearl
Harbor, this democracy was so
mobilized that America had not
only caught up to Nazi Germany,
but was outproducing also
the Axis powers combined
and all the Allied
powers combined,
so that our weapons were
being used by our allies
in all the corners of the world.
It is also the story
of the forgotten years
of the civil rights revolution,
a watershed experience in which
the seeds of the protest
movements of the succeeding
decades were sown.
And it is the story of
more than 19 million women
who poured into factory jobs
during the war previously held
by men, performing beyond
everyone's expectations
as truck drivers, welders,
riveters, and stevedores,
creating new expectations
and new problems
that would ultimately set
the stage for the women's
movement in the decades ahead.
And it is the story of
the GI Bill of Rights,
which carried more than two
million veterans into college
after the war, so much so that
50% of the college enrollment
was veterans in the
late '40s, transforming
higher education,
research institutions,
and lifting the
educational horizons
of an entire generation.
It is this story I wish to tell
you today, using as my vehicle
the remarkable relationship
between Franklin
Roosevelt and his wife,
Eleanor, during the war,
hoping that this personal
narrative will bring you
the larger story of the
homefront and bring it to life.
Let me say at the
outset that, if I
have to point to one quality of
Franklin Roosevelt's that made
and shaped his leadership of
the homefront during the war,
it would be his absolute
confidence in himself,
in his country, and in
the democratic system
of government.
Even in the grimmest
days of 1940,
after France fell to Germany
and England stood alone,
Roosevelt had
absolutely no doubt
that, once the dormant energies
of democracy were mobilized,
the US would fully
meet the German threat,
that the uncoerced
energy of a free people
would inevitably outperform
a totalitarian regime.
It was this confidence
that allowed
him to ship our limited supplies
to England when England stood
alone against Germany,
and it was this confidence
that allowed him to invest
more than $2 billion
in a theoretical enterprise
to build the atomic bomb.
And more importantly, he
was able to communicate
his confidence and faith
to the American people,
helping to energize a massive
shift to a wartime economy,
and helping to bring
about the commitment
of the American citizens
to working three shifts, 24
hours a day, to produce
the unimaginable quantities
of weapons that eventually
did win the war.
He helped to create the
dedication of scientists
and researchers and
universities like this
to produce the groundbreaking
discoveries that improved
radar, created large-scale
production of penicillin,
developed plasma, proximity
fuses, and the jet engines.
His strength came,
in my judgment,
in leading the people step by
step, never getting too far
ahead of them, but always moving
them forward little by little
toward his goals.
And in shaping
public opinion, he
understood intuitively
the importance
of rationing his
appearances, something
our current political leaders
seem not to have understood,
in order to guarantee and
guard the dignity of the office
and to ensure that
each appearance has
a dramatic effect.
Thus, he limited his
celebrated fireside chats
to only two or three a year,
only 30 in the entire 12 years
of his presidency.
And the result was, as
Saul Bellow describes
in a recent memoir, he would
describe walking down a Chicago
street in the middle
of the war when
one of Roosevelt's rare
fireside chats was on the air.
He said that every single
car had pulled over
to the curb to listen, every
single house had it on,
and you could see inside
the windows people sitting
in their living rooms, in
their kitchen with their radios
before them.
He said that it was such
a moment that you felt not
only connected to
Roosevelt's voice,
and he said you could keep
walking down the street
and not miss a word of what he
was saying because everyone was
listening, but you felt
connected to everyone else
in the country because you
realized they, too, were
experiencing that same moment.
And when a leader is able to
create that sense of connection
between the fellow
Americans, it's
probably the greatest
strength that leader has.
I think my favorite Roosevelt
fireside chat took place
in February of
1942, when we were
at one of the lowest depths
of the war, several months
after Pearl Harbor, losing
battles in the Pacific.
He asked everyone in the country
before he gave his address
to get a map out
so that they could
follow the progress of the
war in this far-flung place.
Well, suddenly, there
was this huge run
on maps all across the country,
so much so that the New York
Times interviewed
the guy who ran C.S.
Hammond's map store in New York.
And he had been
there for 25 years.
He said he had never sold so
many maps in his whole time
that he was there.
And then he added this
wonderful comment, he said,
even my wife of 25
years, who hates maps,
asked me to bring a map home.
So then I started thinking,
what kind of a marriage
did these two people have?
This is when you go off
the track as a biographer.
But nevertheless,
she's sitting there
at the kitchen table
like everyone else,
listening to Roosevelt
talk very soberly about why
it will take many months before
the tide of the war will turn,
explaining to them what the
battles are that are going on
in the Pacific.
But then he calls
on American history
to give strength and confidence
to the American people.
He recalls what it was like
for Washington in the winters
at Valley Forge, what it was
like for the pioneers going
over the Rocky
Mountains, what it
was like in the early
days of the Civil War.
And he's so certain that
democracy will win out
over the totalitarian powers
that his speech produces
thousands of
telegrams at the end,
telling him that he has to
go on the air every day.
It's the only way morale
will be sustained.
But he writes back saying,
intuitively understanding,
if my speeches ever
become routine,
they will lose
their effectiveness.
So he understood that prestige
and that majesty, in a sense,
of the presidency, and how
to time his appearances when
they were absolutely necessary.
Indeed, Winston Churchill,
the incomparable leader
himself of England, fully
comprehended the importance
of Roosevelt's confidence
in mobilizing his people.
Churchill once said to encounter
Roosevelt for the first time,
with all his buoyant sparkle,
his iridescent personality,
and his sublime confidence
was like opening
your first bottle of champagne.
Now, this was an
extraordinary comment
coming from a man long
accustomed himself
to being the center
of attention,
but Churchill had come to know
and admire Roosevelt greatly,
having spent weeks and even
months at a time actually
living in the White House,
spending his time in a room
diagonally across from
Roosevelt's bedroom,
bringing his valets, his
stewards, and his habits
with him, which included
starting to drink early
in the morning wine, moving
to Scotch and whiskey
in the middle of the
day and the afternoon,
and ending up at brandy before
he went to bed at night,
and somehow saving England
in the process of all this.
He indeed became part
of an intimate circle
of friends who lived
in those small family
quarters of the White House with
the Roosevelts during the war,
including Franklin's secretary,
Missy LeHand, who really was,
in many ways, his other
wife when Eleanor traveled,
Franklin's closest advisor
and friend, Harry Hopkins, who
occupied a bedroom right next
to his, Eleanor's closest
friend, Lorena Hickok,
who helped her to become
the First Lady that she was,
and lived in a bedroom next
to Eleanor's study, Franklin's
mother, Sarah, who occupied
the best guest suite
whenever she arrived,
and of course Winston Churchill.
I found myself so intrigued by
all these wonderful characters
living in such close
quarters that I
kept imagining the fabulous
conversations they must have
had at night, and wished
so often that I could just
see those family
quarters, to picture who
had lived where 50 years ago.
I happened to mention this on a
radio program in Washington one
night, which Hillary
Clinton heard.
So she called me up
at the radio station
and invited me to sleep
overnight in the White House
so that we could figure
out where everybody
had slept 50 years ago.
So I had this wonderful
night in the White House
where, after a state dinner,
my husband and I wandered
through the rooms with
President and Mrs. Clinton,
and figured out every single
place where everyone had been.
And the best part
of all was that we
realized we were staying in
Winston Churchill's bedroom.
So there was no way I
could sleep that night.
I just kept picturing
Winston Churchill behind me
the whole time.
In fact, one of my
favorite stories of the war
took place in that very bedroom.
In January of 1942, when
Churchill was staying there,
he and Roosevelt were set
to sign a document later
that afternoon putting the
associated nations, 23 of them,
against the Axis powers.
But no one liked the
word associated nations
because it had no
rhythm or ring.
So early that morning,
Roosevelt came up with the idea
that he was so excited about to
call themselves United Nations,
which of course it became.
So he had himself wheeled
into Churchill's bedroom
to tell him the news,
but Churchill had just
stepped forth from the tub
with absolutely nothing on.
So Roosevelt said,
I'm so sorry, I'll
come back in a few minutes.
But Churchill, with that amazing
ability to speak spontaneously,
said, oh, no, the prime
minister of Great Britain
has nothing to hide from the
president of the United States.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
So somehow, while Roosevelt
describes United Nations,
Churchill thinks
it's a great idea.
He then quotes in full
memory from a poem
by Lord Byron where the term
United Nations was used.
So whenever I got into
the tub that night,
then Churchill was really there.
[LAUGHTER]
Indeed, I believe through
all the turmoil of the worst
days of the war,
a central quality
of Roosevelt's character
was his capacity
to relax with his
friends and associates,
to cast off his worries
and simply enjoy himself,
thus replenishing
his energies to face
the struggles of
the following day.
Every night, he had
the same ritual.
He had a cocktail hour
with his associates
on that second
floor, and the rule
was you were not allowed
to talk about politics.
You could talk
gossip, you could tell
who was involved
with whom, you could
discuss movies and Hollywood,
anything but politics.
When Eleanor was away,
his secretary Missy LeHand
presided.
She listened adoringly
to the same old stories
and jokes he liked to
tell over and over again.
When Eleanor did come, she
somehow couldn't help herself
but bring up slum
clearance or civil rights,
but most of the time
the rules prevailed.
And then if he were
anxious during the day,
Missy would arrange
a poker game at night
with his cabinet, which
he loved to relax,
and could again forget
the cares of state.
One of my favorite stories
is he had an annual poker
game on the night that
Congress was set to adjourn.
And the rule was that whenever
the Speaker of the House called
to say they were
adjourning, whoever
was ahead at that moment
would win the poker game.
On one particular
night, he was playing
with Secretary of the Treasury
Morgenthau and several others.
And at 9:30, when
the Speaker called
to say they were
adjourning, Morgenthau
that was way, way
ahead of Roosevelt,
so Roosevelt took
the phone and just
pretended it was someone
else on the phone.
So they kept playing,
and they kept playing,
until midnight when finally
Roosevelt pulled ahead,
so he asked the aide to bring
him the phone immediately.
Oh, Mr. Speaker, you're
adjourning, that's fine.
He brings all the chips,
he wins all the money.
Everything's great until the
next morning, when Morgenthau
reads in the newspaper that the
Congress had adjourned at 9:30.
They said that he was so
angry that he actually
resigned his post as cabinet
member until, of course,
Roosevelt cajoled
him into staying.
Roosevelt was also able
to relax with movies.
He loved adventure movies
and mystery movies.
Again, when Eleanor
did choose the movies,
it would somehow become
The Grapes of Wrath
or a documentary
on civil rights.
And he could relax
on long fishing trips
in the middle of the war, 10-day
fishing trips when he could
be out of touch with people.
It was on one of
these fishing trips,
in fact, when, in the midst
of Britain's financial crisis,
through the solitude
and the time,
his creative juices
came to fruition,
and he was able to come up with
a brilliant idea of Lend-Lease.
And then, from his home in Hyde
Park, where he went 200 times
during his presidency, he
received the enormous solace
of just remembering
a root, a place where
he had known since he
was a child, all of which
allowed him, I think, to make
the presidency not a burden,
as so many other
leaders have found it,
but rather a continual
source of vitality.
And even more
importantly, in some ways,
this peace, this equanimity
that he felt within himself
freed up resources,
psychic resources,
that allowed him to be
extremely receptive to the needs
of others.
He had, the British
philosopher Isaiah Berlin
once suggested, an exceptionally
sensitive awareness,
conscious or subconscious,
of the desires, the hopes,
the fears, the loves, the
hatreds of the human beings
who composed his democracy.
This uncanny awareness,
Berlin argued,
was the source of
Roosevelt's genius.
It was almost as if the
inner currents, the tremors
of human society were
registering themselves
within his nervous system with a
kind of seismological accuracy.
Now, where this uncanny
knowledge came from
is partly a mystery.
As a child, his
mother, Sarah, claimed
Roosevelt was remarkably
intuitive, able
to anticipate the
desires of his parents
even before he was
told what to do,
able to sense the
tensions in the family
when his father became
an invalid, knowing
exactly how to respond.
Then, too, his bout with polio
undoubtedly made him even more
aware of what other people
were thinking and feeling,
ever determined to make sure
that no one felt pity for him.
The polio produced a
plowing up of his nature,
Frances Perkins, his Labor
Secretary, once said.
He became much more
patient, more tolerant,
more warm-hearted, more
empathetic to others
for whom fate had also
dealt an unkind hand.
But I think Franklin
Roosevelt would be the first
to admit that,
beyond his intuition
and beyond his
experience of polio,
his extraordinary knowledge
of the hopes and the fears
and the needs of
the American people
came as a result of his wife
Eleanor's remarkable ramblings
around the country, for she was,
as he said over and over again
after his polio, his
eyes and his ears.
Their partnership was
indeed unparalleled.
She was the first First Lady to
travel the country from one end
to the other, serving
as a voice for people
without power, for poor,
for migrant workers,
for blacks, for women,
the first to testify
before a congressional
committee, the first
to write a syndicated
column, and the first to hold
regular press conferences
where she made
a simple rule that only female
reporters could cover her press
conferences, which meant that
every newspaper in the country
had to hire usually its
first female reporter.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Now, this partnership was
all the more remarkable
when one realizes
that it was born
in the pain of Eleanor's
discovery in 1918
that Franklin was having an
affair with a young woman named
Lucy Mercer.
When Eleanor came upon
a packet of love letters
Lucy had written
to her husband, she
said that the bottom
dropped out of her world.
She offered him a
divorce at once,
but after long discussions,
they agreed to stay together.
He promised he would never
see Lucy Mercer again.
And more importantly,
this catastrophe
in their married life
reconstituted the marriage,
giving Eleanor the freedom
to go outside the marriage
to find fulfillment.
She became involved in teaching
and settlement housework.
She got close to
a group of women
activists who taught her that
she had a whole range of talent
she had never known before,
for public speaking,
for organizing, for
articulating a cause.
And then her activism
became critical
when he contracted
polio three years later
and had to spend
weeks and months
at a time at Warm
Springs, Georgia,
desperately trying to walk
on his own power again.
She kept his political
hopes alive by going
from one meeting to
the other so that, when
he came back and won the
governorship, she was there.
And then when he
became president,
her travels multiplied.
She traveled 200 days
a year, so much so
that the Washington Post
once had a headline,
"Eleanor spends night in White
House," exclamation point.
Visiting southern
blacks, migrant workers,
CCC camps, bringing him back
an honest appraisal of which
of his programs were working
and which were failing,
the kind of evaluation
that leaders rarely get.
Then the war came along and
threatened this partnership,
which had worked so brilliantly
during the Depression, for now
the president was spending
more and more time
with military men,
with businessmen,
with conservatives, with
southern congressmen,
and Eleanor felt that
she had lost her partner,
and in so doing lost
her sense of self.
She cycled into one of
her periodic depressions,
coming out of it only when
she realized there was still
a critical fight to be fought to
try and make the war a vehicle
for social reform at home so
that, when the soldiers came
home at the end of the
war, the country would
be a more socially just place.
It meant she had to become
an agitator, often working
at cross purposes
with her husband,
for his sole concern
was to win the war.
She had to be
relentless, often a pest,
but he understood the
importance of what
she was pushing him to do, and
his presidency was immeasurably
enriched as a result.
Nowhere was her influence
greater than on civil rights.
At the start of the war, blacks
were openly discriminated
against in the factories.
But through the combination
of A. Philip Randolph
threatening a march on
Washington and Eleanor's
negotiations, Franklin
Roosevelt agreed
to create the first
Fair Employment Practice
Commission with sanctions
to force companies
to open their doors to blacks.
And by the end of the war,
more than two million blacks
had jobs at all levels of
skills in factories they never
would have had before.
I was able to interview
one of these men, who
became the first black motorman
in the Philadelphia mass
transit system.
And he told me he had
scored 95 on the test,
and he was so excited
his first morning
on the job he got to the
station, to the bus station,
early, but there were no
buses running, no trolleys,
no trains, no subways.
He didn't know
what had happened.
He went home to discover that
the 10,000 white workers had
all gone on strike because
he, the first black man,
was coming to work that day.
So the strike went
on for four days,
paralyzing Philadelphia's
war production system,
until finally Roosevelt
took decisive action.
He issued a very
simple statement.
He told the striking workers,
if they did not come back
to work on Monday,
they would all
be drafted on Tuesday morning.
They came back to work.
And on Tuesday
morning, William Barber
became the first black
motorman in Philadelphia.
So, too, in the military.
Whereas at the start
of the war blacks
were serving in the lowest level
jobs in the Army and the Navy,
by the end, through the
combination of the growing
civil rights movement
and Eleanor's agitation,
they were serving in every
branch of the Army and Navy,
as pilots, tank men,
doctors, paratroopers,
and the number of black officers
had grown from five in 1940
to over 7,000 in 1945.
It took so many memos on
Eleanor's part on civil rights
to poor General Marshall
in the War Department,
who was trying to
create an army,
that he finally had to
create a separate general
just to deal with Eleanor
Roosevelt's communications.
But her pressure worked.
And in many ways, it seems
to me that her contributions
on civil rights are
some of the most
affirming moments in the
history of the homefront.
But she was also far
ahead of her time
in championing the movement
of women into the factories
during the war.
Through her speeches
and her columns,
she countered the
early resistance
on the part of factory
owners to employing women.
They never thought the women
could operate these complicated
machines.
They thought women would disrupt
the camaraderie at the factory.
But once more and more
men went off to the war,
they had to turn to women.
And eventually, by the middle
of the war, 50% and 60%
of the shipyards
and the factories
that were making the planes,
the jobs were held by women.
And the amazing thing was
the productivity went way up.
So these factory owners
had to do a big study
to figure out how
it had happened
that women had been
able to learn to operate
these complicated machines.
And I love the answer that came
back on one of the studies.
They said it was very simple.
When a woman was
asked to operate
a new piece of
machinery, unlike a man,
she would ask directions.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
I think any of us who
have ever driven endlessly
around without directions being
asked know what that's about.
Well then, once Eleanor
saw the importance of women
to the war effort,
it was she who
convinced government
and business
to create a full-fledged
partnership to create daycare
centers operating
24 hours a day,
almost like a Head Start
program for the children
during that period of time.
They worked out a
situation where,
if you worked a day shift, a
hot meal was waiting for you
at the end of the
day to bring home
to your family, all of which
allowed that productivity
to continue unmatched,
and was an example
of the unparalleled partnership
of Franklin and Eleanor.
Now, to be sure, Roosevelt's
sensitive antennae,
in part helped by Eleanor,
produced occasional problems.
So skillful was he in sensing
what other people wanted
him to say that he often made
people feel he was agreeing
with them and what they
were saying when he really
wasn't agreeing at all.
Perhaps in the long run,
one disillusioned aide
said fewer friends would
have been lost by bluntness
than by the misunderstandings
that arose from his engaging
and charming ambiguity.
Moreover, so desirous was he
of making other people like him
that he was unable
to fire anyone,
neither his isolationist
Secretary of War Henry
Woodring until the crisis
finally occurred in Western
Europe, nor his drunken valet
who was supposed to help him
every morning out of
bed into the bathroom,
nor the dramatic housekeeper
who refused to prepare
the meals for him that he liked,
saying that she knew better
what was good for him.
One must also concede
more serious failures
of perception and
vision that led
to his forcible relocation
of the Japanese-Americans
and the lack of a
more decisive response
to the extermination
of the European Jews.
And yet, in the end, I believe
Roosevelt's strengths far
outweighed his weaknesses.
Despite clashing interests
and disparate goals,
he kept the American
people moving forward
together through
the two greatest
crises of this century, first
the Depression, and then
the war.
And always he kept his
strength on the side
of freedom and his trust
in the uncoerced energy
of the ordinary citizen.
Through the whole of
Franklin's career,
Eleanor once said, despite
maneuvering and flexibility
and some deviousness,
there was never
any deviation from
his original objective
to make life better for the
average man, woman, and child.
Indeed, it was Eleanor's
abiding love and deep respect
for Roosevelt's great strengths
as a leader that allowed her,
in the months after
his death, to come
to terms with the deep hurts
in their personal relationship.
During the war, Roosevelt had
suffered a series of losses.
His secretary, Missy
LeHand, though she was only
in her early 40s, suffered
a devastating stroke,
and was never able to
speak intelligibly again.
Three months later, his mother,
Sarah, died at Hyde Park.
At that point, he
turned to Eleanor
and asked her essentially to
stay home and stop traveling.
He needed her even more
as a companion than as
a political partner.
It's one of those moments
when, as a biographer,
you want to reach back in time
and say, Eleanor, just do it.
I know that you love him
and I know he loves you,
and I know he won't
live much longer.
But I understand fully why she
couldn't make that commitment.
She'd been so hurt
so many years before,
and had built up slowly a sense
of herself in the outside world
that she couldn't give up.
So she started
traveling more and more,
and in his
loneliness, he finally
brought their eldest
daughter, Anna,
in to take Missy's place as
his hostess in the White House
when Eleanor was away.
It became complicated
for, when Eleanor
would return from
her trips, sometimes
she would feel displaced by her
own daughter, with whom she'd
been very close.
She had confided in Anna early
on the story of Lucy Mercer,
and Anna had strongly
taken her mother's side.
But now, in many
ways, Anna was now
becoming her father's daughter.
Everything got more
complicated in that last year
of Roosevelt's life,
when, in spring of 1944,
he was diagnosed with
congestive heart failure.
He was sent to Bernard
[? Baruch's ?] plantation
to recuperate for a month,
and it was there essentially
that he saw Lucy Mercer for
the first time since 1918.
She'd married a very
wealthy older man
named Winthrop Rutherfurd,
lived in South Carolina not far
from [? Baruch's ?] plantation,
and Rutherfurd had just died
several months before that.
I'm convinced that, in
seeing Lucy at this point,
it was simply a
friendship in his life.
It may have rekindled
him a memory of what
it was like when he was young,
before his polio, a memory
of what it was like when
his body was strong,
before the heart disease that
was now deteriorating him day
by day.
But he didn't trust that
Eleanor would understand
that it was simply a
friendship, and must
have remembered
the pledge that he
had made so many years before.
So he realized the only way
he could see Lucy regularly
would be to have her
come to the White House
when Eleanor was away.
And the only person he trusted
with that delicate task
was his daughter, Anna.
You can imagine the dilemma
that Anna found herself in,
knowing what it would
mean to her mother
if she ever found out.
But Anna could see that her
father was dying in a way
that Eleanor never did, and as
a result Anna made the decision
to allow Lucy to come
to the White House six
times in that last year
of Roosevelt's life,
always having dinner
with Roosevelt.
And I've checked, and Eleanor
was doing what she wanted to
at that period of time.
She was with women when they
won awards for excellence
in the factory, with
civil rights leaders when
the laws came down desegregating
the [? PX's ?] in the Army
camp.
So it all might have worked
out with no one being
hurt but for the fact
that Lucy happened
to be in Warm Springs,
Georgia when Franklin died.
She knew enough to leave, but
when Eleanor flew down later
that night, a spinster cousin
who was there and always been
jealous of Eleanor,
always loved Franklin,
when asked to describe what
had happened in that last day,
as you would do at
a moment of death,
told her that Lucy
had been there.
And even more, that Lucy
had been at the White House
many times that last year,
and that her daughter
Anna had been the one to
make those visits possible.
I can't even imagine
the dignity that Eleanor
was able to muster within
herself that allowed her
to go with her husband's
body on the famous train trip
from Warm Springs to Washington
DC, never letting the world
know the hurt she must
have been feeling inside.
When she got to the White
House, she confronted Anna.
All that Anna could say was
I didn't know what to do,
I loved you both so much and
felt caught in a crossfire.
And Anna later said her
mother was so angry with her
that she was sure that
their relationship had
been destroyed forever.
But then, in the summer of
1945, after his death in April,
something happened
in Eleanor's heart,
as she began traveling
the country again.
For everywhere
she went, people--
porters, taxi drivers,
elevator operators--
told her how much they
loved her husband,
how much better their lives were
as a result of his leadership.
Blacks shared with her a sense
of the mastery of the jobs
that they had felt, the
pride and the courage
they took in the battlefield.
Women talked of the
new independence
they had found during
the war, the pleasure
and the sociability
of the workplace,
the feeling of accomplishment.
Though the factories
were already
firing women to make room
for the returning men,
though the daycare centers were
being shut down unceremoniously
as the war was
drawing to a close,
there had been a
permanent shifting away
from the women's consciousness,
a powerful turning
point in the history of women.
Work had proved liberating,
a new consciousness
had been formed, and there
would be no going back.
She talked to veterans who
were going to college on the GI
Bill of Rights, where, despite
overcrowding in housing
and classrooms,
they were determined
to make the most of their most
extraordinary opportunity.
She talked to laborers
who took pride in the fact
that unions were stronger at
the end of the war than ever
before, despite Roosevelt's
partnership with business
that had so worried Eleanor
at the start of the war.
She'd been fighting him on
so many fronts during the war
that she had lost sight
of the larger picture,
but now she realized that
the war had indeed become
a vehicle for social
reform in more ways
than she ever could
have imagined.
The small-town America where
people clung to their roots,
immobilized within their
ethnic and income class,
had passed into history.
Between the 50
million Americans who
had moved to a different part
of the country to find work
and the 12 million more who
entered the armed forces,
more than 20% of
the population had
participated in what became
known as the Great Migration.
And the habit of
mobility, which would
prove both liberating
and fragmenting,
had become ingrained.
No segment of American society
had been left untouched.
More than 17 million new
jobs had been created.
Industrial production
had gone up 100%.
Corporate profits had doubled.
And the GNP had jumped from
100 billion to 215 billion.
The society of a few haves
and a multitude of have nots
had been transformed.
A redistribution of income had
produced a genuine middle class
for the first time.
Moreover, the pent-up demand,
desire matched by money,
would fuel a postwar boom that
would expand that middle class
still further.
And the American economy had
not been merely revitalized,
it had been altered.
A revised social
contract had been
defined between government
and the business community,
a new partnership like
the new partnership
between the government
and the universities that
would alter the face of the
country in the decades ahead.
As Eleanor began to absorb the
extent of all these changes,
she began to feel, she later
said, in a somewhat romantic
image, as if a giant
transference of energy
had taken place, that
at the start of the war
Roosevelt was strong and
productive and vital,
and the country was weak,
unprepared, and isolationist.
But by the end, through his
projection of his energy
onto the country,
the country had
gotten stronger and stronger,
while he was drained of energy
and got weaker and weaker.
And finally, he had
died, but the country
had emerged stronger and more
socially just than ever before.
As she listened to the emotion
in the voices of all the people
who talked with her about
what he had done for them,
she was able to
reach within herself
and to forgive him
fully for resuming
that friendship with Lucy in
the last year of his life.
And then, just as the
war came to an end,
after six long
years of struggle,
to go to her daughter
Anna and forgive her,
as well, affording
a reconciliation
between mother and daughter
that re-established
a close relationship
between the two women
that lasted for the
rest of their lives.
So in conclusion, as I
look at this complex story
of the American
homefront during the war,
I can only say I feel empathy
for both Franklin and Eleanor.
I'm absolutely
convinced they never
meant to hurt one another.
They were simply trying
to get through their lives
with the best possible
mixture of respect
and affection through
friendship, work, and love.
Sure, it is possible to
look from the outside in,
as the media would immediately
do today, and accuse Roosevelt
of infidelity for resuming
his friendship with Lucy,
accuse him perhaps
even of harassment
for his close relationship with
his secretary Missy LeHand,
and accuse the daughter Anna
of betrayal of her mother.
But every one of those
labels, in my judgment,
would totally miss
the mark of trying
to understand the lives of
these large individuals.
For in the end, I believe
the real challenge of history
is to resist the
tendency so prevalent
today to label, to
stereotype, to expose,
to denigrate, and instead
to bring common sense
and empathy to our subjects
so that the past can truly
come alive, if only
for a few moments,
in all of its beauty, glory,
sadness, and complexity.
I thank you so very much.
[APPLAUSE]
GRAY: Doris, thank you so much
for that wonderfully insightful
portrait of America and
of American leadership
during the war.
Your comments,
particularly on the way
in which the war and
the leadership provided
by the Roosevelts changed the
social assumptions for blacks
and women, I think
are particularly
important for us to understand.
And I hope that many people,
including many in the media,
listen to your plea at
the end to step away
from the stereotypes
and to express empathy
and understanding for
those in leadership
positions in our nation.
One wonders what the world
of 1995 would be like
had not Franklin Roosevelt
been in the White House
in the 1940s, and had not
Winston Churchill been at 10
Downing Street.
I suspect, Doris,
that, as there was
a run on maps in
February of 1942,
there will soon be a run on No
Ordinary Time in June of 1995.
[APPLAUSE]
I will now introduce the next
four speakers, after which
we will proceed
without interruption
or without further
words from me.
Because all four are familiar
figures at the Institute,
I shall be brief in
these introductions.
Now, early publicity
for this program,
including particularly the
poster that many of you
have seen, indicated
that Sheila E. Widnall,
Secretary of the Air
Force and professor
of Aeronautics and
Astronautics at MIT, on leave,
would be a participant.
Unfortunately, the
gnomes in the Pentagon
concluded that her appearance
would somehow constitute
a conflict of interest.
How that can be devised is
beyond me, but in any case,
Sheila had no choice
but to withdraw.
That withdrawal saddened
her fully as much
as it did all of us
who were involved
in planning this program.
Our next speaker,
Robert C. Seamans Jr.,
has been associated with
MIT for more than 50 years.
He earned two degrees from the
Institute, a master's degree
in aeronautics in
1942 and an [? SCD, ?]
a doctor of science, in
instrumentation in 1951.
During the next 40 years,
he shuttled back and forth
between Cambridge
and Washington.
I list just some of his
activities in that time.
Deputy administrator of
NASA during that key time
in which NASA was so involved
in the Apollo program.
Hunsaker Professor of
Aeronautics and Astronautics
at MIT.
Secretary of the Air Force.
President of the National
Academy of Engineering.
First administrator of the
Energy Research and Development
Agency, which became later
the Department of Energy.
The [? Lutz ?] Professor of
Environment and Public Policy
at MIT.
Dean of Engineering at MIT.
And now, senior lecturer in
Aeronautics and Astronautics
here.
Bob will speak from his
personal experience about MIT
during the war years.
Now, the speaker
following Bob, who
will comment on the ways
in which the war influenced
the Institute, deserves
no introduction.
[LAUGHTER]
The third speaker--
--the third speaker is
Lester C. Thurow, Jerome
and Dorothy Lemelson Professor
of Management and Economics
here, dean of the Sloan
School of Management
from 1987 to 1993, and,
as Lester would put it,
economics educator.
Following his graduation from
Williams College in 1960,
Lester went to Oxford
as a Rhodes scholar,
and earned his PhD in
economics at Harvard in 1964.
After serving a term as a
member of the staff of President
Lyndon Johnson's Council
of Economic Advisers,
he taught at Harvard
in economics,
before coming to MIT to
join our faculty in 1968.
Lester is a prolific
author, and his four books
have received very
wide attention.
His most recent
book, Head to Head--
The Coming Economic Battle Among
Japan, Europe, and America,
published in 1992,
describes what
Americans must do to
regain competitiveness
in the world economy.
Lester has been on leave
from MIT this last year,
and it would surprise
me if there's not
another book in the works.
He writes a regular column
for the Boston Globe.
Lester will speak today
about the economic impact
of the war on American society.
Our fourth and final
speaker is Charles Vest,
who needs practically no
introduction to this group
of loyal alumni and friends.
Chuck is a graduate in
mechanical engineering
from West Virginia University
and the University of Michigan,
where he served as Dean
of Engineering and later
as Provost and Vice President
for Academic Affairs,
before he was called to come to
Cambridge in the summer of 1990
to assume the
Institute's presidency.
Chuck is the 15th president
of the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology.
He will reflect this morning
on the future of relationships
between the federal government
and this nation's universities,
relationships forged largely
out of the cauldron of the war.
It is now my pleasure to invite
Bob Seamans to the lectern.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good morning.
- While I move the
podium up, I would
like to say that I'm very
much in debt to the MIT museum
for going through reams
and reams of cartons
and notebooks and
loose photographs
in order to come up
with the material
that I'm going to use
here this morning.
I should also note that, when
you look at these slides,
they'll seem rather drab.
And of course, you
have to realize
that, back in the early '40s,
Kodachrome was not in wide use.
So now let me see if we
can get a slide here.
Good.
This is MIT prior
to World War II.
Not too clear the campus.
You won't be able to
see it too clearly,
so I'm going to take
you on a walk around it.
I will note that MIT
started in Boston,
so I'll proceed across
the Mass Avenue Bridge.
And as we come across
Memorial Drive,
we'll see the main
building on the right.
We'll see the Graduate
House on the left,
which is now [? Ashdown. ?]
This is followed by the Coop.
And then we come to
Bexley Hall, then
a very nondescript building
that had such places in it
as Walton's, where
you could get somewhat
of a luncheon for $0.82,
and then the Armory.
Directly across
from the Armory was
the Guggenheim
Aeronautical Laboratory,
building 33, which actually
had open parking behind it.
[LAUGHTER]
As we stop at the light that's
usually red on Vassar Street,
we note to the left the
Metropolitan Storage,
and on the--
almost directly ahead,
but somewhat on the right,
the Whittemore Shoe
Polish Building,
which the Instrumentation Lab
would occupy very shortly.
We head north, we go by lots
and lots of empty space.
And we could note, if
we are history-minded,
that it was here that, in
1915, the first building was
put on this campus.
It was Jerry
Hunsaker's wind tunnel,
roughly a year before MIT
moved across en masse.
Beyond the Main Street,
proceed down towards Kendall,
turn the corner onto Ames.
We go by the buildings, the
dormitories on the East Campus,
and we end up with Walker
Memorial on our right
and the president's
house on the left.
Now, it was in June 1941 that I
had completed my studies here,
except for a thesis.
So one nice, sunny day,
rather than go out sailing,
I thought I might so go in town
and have a chat with Doc Draper
to see what I might do
in the fall on a thesis
when he, said would you like
to work on vibration measuring
equipment?
And I said that'd be fine.
Would you like to
get paid for it?
Well, a new thought.
I said that'd be terrific.
[LAUGHTER]
He said, OK, then you've
got to start this week.
So that's when I started
getting paid at MIT.
I think my first salary
was $1,200 a year.
The person I was working with
down in the basement of 33,
right near where
the crash came out,
was named [? Barney ?]
[? Oldfield. ?] And I noticed
he was coming in less and less,
and then suddenly I heard that
he'd been in the reserve and he
was going to the Signal Corps.
This is the end of August.
And at that point,
Doc Draper came around
and he said, how would you
like to be an instructor?
And I said, well, I'd have
to go up in front of a class.
And he said, well,
you may have to.
[LAUGHTER]
But I accepted the challenge.
And then there was a
custom in those days
that, at the first
faculty meeting,
the new faculty and
the new instructors
were introduced by Karl Compton.
And what I didn't know
was each was supposed
to stand up and,
in one sentence,
describe who they were
and what they were doing.
When it came my turn,
I sort of blurted out,
I said, I'm nothing but
a Harvard man interested
in vibration equipment.
And about two weeks later, I
ran across my father in town,
and he said, by the way, do
you know that other Harvard man
at MIT who has the jitters?
[LAUGHTER]
Now, our world
changed dramatically
in about two months.
In December 1941,
President Compton
wasn't using that house
that I've mentioned
as much as he used to.
He was traveling a
great deal of the time.
And here he is touring the
South Pacific in his role
as Chief of Field Services
in the Office of Scientific
Research and Development, OSRD.
OSRD was headed
by Vannevar Bush,
who was the former dean
of engineering and vice
president of MIT.
Van had left MIT before
the war to become
president of the Carnegie
Institution of Washington.
And it was from his
office there that he
ran the scientific and technical
effort during World War II,
reporting directly
to the person we've
heard so much about and so
eloquently this morning,
President Roosevelt.
Compton's presidential
report of October 1945
was written while
in the field, and is
the basis for much of my talk.
In the report, he notes the
total participation of MIT
in World War II.
30% of the staff took
leaves of absence,
and 25%, a quarter of all alumni
from MIT were in the military,
including 92 generals
and 35 admirals.
On campus, there were many
special educational courses
and 400 research and
development contracts.
MIT was reimbursed five million
by the government for education
and training, and 93 million for
the research and development.
And that was in '45 dollars.
Now, there were many
course completion photos
similar to this one
of postgraduates
of naval construction
and engineering.
Captain Joyce was head
of the military training
here at MIT at that time,
and Professor Manning
of the naval architecture
in the foreground.
I myself ended up with 13 such
photos, each time with Captain
Joyce and 50 V12 officers who
had taken my course in aircraft
instrumentation.
These are six-week courses
that ended on Friday.
The following Monday, the
next group would come in.
And so it went for 13 times.
Now, the scope of what went
on at MIT and in education
is really hard to get across.
This is sort of an
attempt, a photograph taken
from inside MIT looking
out on the Killian Court.
And you can see large numbers,
in this case of enlisted men
who went through training here.
All told, there were 2,300
in the Navy V12 and Army
specialized training
groups, there
were 7,275 in the Army and Navy
who attended the radar school
down Atlantic Avenue, and
there were nearly 1,000
in meteorology and
weather forecasting.
Now, MIT, of course, was
more than the classrooms.
Interest in aeronautics expanded
during the '20s and '30s,
with such notables as Donald
Douglas and Jimmy Doolittle
receiving their
doctor's degrees.
Dr. [? Hunsaker ?] returned
to MIT in the mid '30s as head
of mechanical engineering
and of the new aeronautical
engineering department.
He had much to do, obviously,
with the construction
of this much larger wind
tunnel than he had first
built on the campus.
This slide is from the
roof of the Aero building
facing towards
MIT's main building.
And the design of this wind
tunnel and so on came out
of the leadership of
Professor Joe Bicknell.
The tunnel was put
in operation in 1939.
The 400 government contracts
I mentioned earlier
did not include the
275 orders specifically
for wind tunnel work.
The tunnel operated
on two shifts
throughout the war,
seven days a week,
testing many of the aircraft
designs used in World War II
and weeding out many that
should not have been built.
Now, while at MIT, Vannevar
Bush did a lot of things.
Here he is second from
the left in this slide.
Among other things, he developed
the first differential analyzer
used to solve
differential equations.
It was made from
gears and shafts
and mechanical integrators.
It was called the
Great Brass Brain.
He's leaning on the main
console of the second analyzer
of his design.
In this design, the
gears and shafts
were replaced by
amplifiers and servos.
This machine, called the
Rockefeller Differential
Analyzer, was used to compute
range tables and tenor
patterns, and many designed
equations and so on.
For example, for Doc Draper's
fire control systems.
The photo also includes
Professor [? Phillips, ?] head
of math, on the left, Professor
[? Hazen, ?] head of electrical
engineering, and then Professor
Caldwell on the right,
head of the Center of Analysis.
Not shown is the person you
worked with when you used
the machine, named
Frank [? Rizzu. ?]
You'd go in the room and
it would be operating,
and there are
typewriters-- that's
how you got the data out--
clacking away, clickety click.
And all of a sudden, you'd find
that the machine had stopped.
Frank would meet us all over
the place, consoles everywhere.
He'd go over to one machine,
look at it carefully,
kick the bottom panel, and away
the machine would go again.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, I seem to
have slid a slide.
I wish that time permitted
a full discussion
of all the special facilities
pressed into service
during World War II.
Professor Evans,
[? Rob Lee ?] Evans,
cyclotron was used to produce
radioactive tracers from
medicine and metallurgy
as a means for preserving
[? whole ?] blood.
In the Laboratory
for Insulation,
Dr. von Hippel developed
insulating and dielectric
materials for operation in
high-frequency electric fields.
In 1940, MIT had plans
for a new building
for the chemical engineering
department, but no funds.
Under an agreement
with the Army,
the building was constructed
and used for chemical warfare
services during the war in the
leadership of such individuals
as Professor Whitman
and Gilliland.
Deadly devices, such as
flamethrowers and incendiaries,
were tested here, as well
as production processes
for phosgene and mustard gas.
Such work was done in a
specially protected area
inside the building, with some
of the space well below ground.
Now, shortly after the
war, much of MIT's effort
was revealed to the public.
Here's a flamethrower
operating on MIT's campus
behind the Smith House,
one of the eateries
we had on Memorial Drive.
I'm told extra oil
was added to the fuel
to provide a little more smoke
for demonstration purposes.
I'll make no comment on
whether an environmental impact
statement would have allowed
this to have taken place today.
The Radiation Lab at MIT
was the national center
for work on radar and
other devices that
relied on electromagnetic
wave propagation.
There were similar centers
for other such areas
at other universities
throughout the country.
The lab was started in
1940, well before the war.
At its peak, it had 1,200 staff
and 2,700 support personnel,
and occupied 15
acres of floor space
on campus, and many outlying
facilities here and abroad.
Sir Robert Watson-Watt
was the inventor
of the magnetron, the
key element, of course,
in radar systems.
There are two such
magnetrons, shown
in this slide, one held
by Sir Henry [? Tizard, ?]
who headed the
British mission that
brought the secret of the
magnetron and the magnetron
to this country in 1940.
He's shown here at MIT's
mid-century convocation,
with [? Leto ?]
[? Bridge ?] on the right,
who directed the laboratory, and
Alfred [? Loomis, ?] chairman
of the OSRD-affiliated microwave
committee that had government
oversight of the
laboratory's program.
Now, I'd like to
first just run quickly
through the process that took
place in this laboratory.
It had to start with ideas, with
analyses and design studies.
And next, as you can
see in this slide,
you had to build up breadboards.
And these are being inspected
by two very key players,
Professors
[? Zacharias ?] and Hill.
Next, you had to
run tests to see
how the equipment is working.
And when I ran
across this slide,
I thought it was terrific.
I've never seen such a kludge
of equipment in my life.
It's appended to the side
of one of the radiation lab
temporary buildings.
And building 20, which
you can see if you
want to take a look at it.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, this has a big
pendulum underneath,
which could be swung around,
and the stabilization device
was riding on it.
And with the mirrors
up above, you
could tell whether stabilization
was taking place or not.
The laboratory had a
plethora of radomes
protruding from many rooftops.
Properly designed, they were
transparent to the microwave
equipment inside, and so it was
possible to test the equipment
with signals coming
from either the ground
or from overhead flights.
Now, the laboratory's
output could
be in the form of reports,
design drawings, trained
personnel, or hardware
delivered to test sites
or often to the front lines.
And so I thought this was
a pretty revealing slide.
It shows actually
eight trucks loaded
to the gills ready to
take equipment, possibly
out to Bedford, possibly other
places in the United States.
Maybe over to be shipped--
maybe over to the harbor
to be shipped overseas.
Now, here you see a van, on
top of which is Lee Davenport
and [? Evon ?] [? Getting ?]
with the project officer,
Colonel Warner.
They're on top of a
van for the SCR-584.
This set was produced by GE,
Chrysler, and Westinghouse.
It was used for tracking,
for fire control
of incoming targets,
incoming enemy targets.
The dollar value of the
SCR-584 production I'm told
exceeded the cost
of Boulder dam.
It was used on many
theaters of the war.
The antenna of the microwave
early warning radar, MEW,
is shown here with
B-24s overhead.
Five sets were built by MIT
prior to industrial production.
Several days after
the first installation
in southern England,
American heavy bombers
were somewhat off course.
They were detected 250 miles
to the south of England.
But they were detected
with this equipment,
and were brought back to
their proper bases in England.
Now, to make use
of this equipment,
there had to be some place
where the information could
be received, could be
analyzed, and could be
dispatched where it was needed.
This happens to be the
Eighth Air Force MEW control
room, where enemy aircraft
could be detected and tracked
by observing the radar
scopes, and then, as required,
plotted up on maps and
used by the controllers
to vector friendly aircraft
into position for attack.
This is Loran ground station.
They often had to be placed
in remote, unfriendly places,
such as this one.
A navigation fix was obtained by
receiving simultaneous signals
from three of these, one master
and two slaves [INAUDIBLE]
appropriately to such places
as Greenland and Iceland
and so on.
The system proved useful for
both aircraft and ships at sea.
The Navy's convoys
found this system
particularly advantageous
when zigzagging
on the northern routes
in adverse weather
with submarines in the vicinity.
Luis Alvarez headed
the radiation lab team
that developed the ground
control approach, GCA,
for landing aircraft in fog
and haze, of which there
was plenty in England.
The ground controller could
see the aircraft's deviation
from the approach path, and
could so advise the pilot.
He could talk him in
to a blind landing.
This slide shows
a B-17 located out
at the Bedford airport, part
of the radiation laboratory's
installation there.
You can see the
radome coming down
under the nose of the B-17,
just aft of the gunner's turret.
This so-called H2X
navigation system
that was installed there was
coupled with a Norden bombsight
permitted bombing
through the overcast.
The first 12 installations
were built and installed
by radiation lab personnel
on B-17s like this one
here at the Bedford airport.
General Eaker sent 12 of
his most experienced crews
to MIT to train and
test this equipment.
They then flew the
aircraft to England
to serve as pathfinders
on all major raids
into Germany from November
8, 1943 to March 15, 1944.
During World War
II, Doc Draper was
director of the
instrumentation lab,
and later became head
of the Aero Department.
The key to the fire control
system was not the magnetron,
it was the
single-degree-of-freedom gyro
that he's holding in his hand.
The first breadboard
fire control system
was built for the British,
prior to America's entry
into World War II.
With our declaration of war, all
property of the United States
became part and parcel
of our own military.
And they took over this
piece of equipment,
which was put in a black box.
It was called the shoe box.
Our own Navy wanted to
see how it operated.
It was out at the
Watertown Arsenal.
And the night before it
was to be demonstrated,
somebody made a mistake and
put the wrong damping fluid
in the gyro, so as the
target, which was on a cable,
went across one
side of the arsenal,
and the 20-caliber
started firing
with somebody looking
through the site,
the Navy was very impressed
that all the bullets
seemed to hit the target.
What they didn't find
out until much later
was that the person who
was doing the firing
had done it enough beforehand so
he didn't have to use the site.
[LAUGHTER]
It was non-operational.
This design evolved into
the Mark 14 Gunsight,
which was mounted directly on
50-caliber and 20-millimeter
guns.
50,000 were produced by the
Sperry Gyroscope Company
and its associates, including
[? Dole ?] [? Cam, ?] a local
company that evolved from a
machine shop during the war.
The gunsights were updated
as the enemy became
more proficient and skillful.
Radar ranging was added
first, and then the gunsight
was redesigned to include
a six-power telescope.
This new sight, the Mark
15, is shown in this slide.
It's on the roof of the
Whittemore Shoe Polish
Building, looking
across at the warehouse.
The sight is off-mounted away
from the gun on a hand control
pedestal.
Better to aim the sight.
The gun mounts move
with a pedestal
using drives engineered
in part by Gordon
Brown and his
servomechanism laboratory.
This [? director ?]
system was used
with 20 and 40-millimeter
quads and three-inch 70 guns.
Kamikazes particularly
learned how
to spook the system by attacking
with the sun behind them.
Late in the war, radar signals
were introduced into the sight
so the firing could take place
without visual tracking, when
the target could
not be observed,
either because of the sun or
because of smoke from gunfire.
Unfortunately, time
doesn't permit my
doing justice to all of the
research and development
underway at MIT
during World War II.
Aircraft propulsion was
the province of Eddie
and [? Faye ?] Taylor,
who specialized
on liquid and air-cooled
internal combustion engine.
Work was conducted at MIT on
hiding important facilities
by camouflage, as well
as ferreting them out
at night with airborne
flash photography, pioneered
by Doc Edgerton.
Food processing
and packaging was
important to all of services.
[? Bernie ?] [? Proctor ?]
and [? John ?] [? Sluter ?]
developed pre-cooked frozen
foods that could be thawed out
during a long flight in a B-17.
Professor Van de Graaff
developed and built
five high-voltage generators
for the Navy used for inspection
of castings and munitions.
Other areas of activity
listed on this chart
include work on metal
extraction, new alloys,
surgical sutures,
synthetic rubber, vitamins,
and long-range
weather forecasting.
It was also Professor
[? Holland ?]
[? Williams' ?] work on fuels
and combustion and Professor
[? Keyes ?] and [? Collins ?] on
liquid oxygen, its production,
transportation, and storage
on submarines and aircraft
and for use in welding
and in hospitals.
It's important to note
that MIT was not working
in any way on the atomic bomb.
That is not listed
on this chart.
As President Compton
stated in his 1945 report,
the great commitment to radar
obviated the opportunity
to participate in the most
portentous scientific program
in all history.
This final slide shows
MIT post World War II.
The open area along
Vassar and Main Street
has been filled with temporary
buildings used by the radiation
lab during World War II.
After the war, they were
used to great advantage,
as the MIT student body
dramatically expanded.
Many of these students were
supported by the GI Bill.
Temporary housing was
added on the West Campus,
as you can see, to
accommodate the large number
of married students,
many with children.
I hope I've made it
clear to all of you
that MIT contributed
to America's war effort
in many, many ways, in
many, many disciplines.
Let me conclude by quoting
from Karl Compton's
presidential report.
"The performance of the
Massachusetts Institute
of Technology through our
alumni, staff, and organization
has demonstrated more
vividly than ever
before the essential
soundness of her conception,
the public value of her
work, and the justification
for her continued
endeavor to pioneer
in the oncoming lines of
technological progress.
It is in times of stress
that strength is proved,
but God grant that our future
demonstrations of strength
may be made with full
effect under the stress
of a strong urge to be
useful in peace, and never
again under the dread
compulsion of war."
And he--
[APPLAUSE]
--and now, as I
try to figure out
how to lower the podium
for our next speaker,
because he may have a
little difficulty looking
at his notes, here it goes down.
The next speaker would
not introduce himself.
I'll tell you who it is.
It's Dr. Paul Gray.
And he's going to tell us about
MIT's response to World War II.
Paul?
[APPLAUSE]
GRAY: Thank you very much, Bob.
This is approximately the
halfway point in the program,
so before I begin,
let me invite everyone
to stand in place for about
a one-minute stretch, OK?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GRAY: Thank you very much.
Before I begin my
remarks, I would
like to express my appreciation
to three people who
helped enormously in putting
this material together.
First is Helen Samuels,
the Institute archivist
who guided me in a search
through for materials
in the archives.
Second is Michael Yates
of the MIT Museum, who
helped in providing
me with some slides,
some photographs I
will use this morning.
And third is Lydia Snover of
the MIT Planning Office, who
assembled some of
the data I will show,
and also prepared
those illustrations.
I'm indebted to
all three of them.
The 134-year history of
the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology is
marked, I believe,
by three discontinuities,
transformations
which, in scale or
character or import,
made all the
difference in shaping
the future of this place.
First, the move in 1916 from
Copley Square to Cambridge
liberated the Institute,
then known as Boston Tech,
from its constrained
physical environment,
and permitted expansion of its
programs and its facilities.
That move, made possible by
the extraordinary support
of a very small band
of loyal alumni,
and by the generosity
of George Eastman,
also marked the first steps
in MIT's transformation
from a commuter college to
a residential environment.
Second, the appointment in
1930 of Karl Taylor Compton
as president began the
transformation of the Institute
from an undergraduate
college focused
on engineering,
architecture, and technology
to a science-based university
by strengthening greatly
the sciences.
KT knew that the
future greatness of MIT
depended on developing
first-rate programs
of education and research in
science and applied science.
And he acted on that conviction.
The third discontinuity
is, of course,
the one on which we focus
today, the Second World
War and its effects
on the Institute.
The war-driven
transformation of MIT,
and of essentially all
American universities,
began early in the 1940s
with the mobilization
of scientific and
engineering talent
in the interest of
national defense,
as Bob Seamans has
just described.
It was appropriate that
Bob gave so much attention
to the radiation
laboratory, which in a way
was the largest, most
prominent, but certainly not
the only activity of that kind.
The radiation
laboratory developed
in so many forms radar as an
important tool of warfare.
It was said after the war
by I.I. Rabi, I believe,
that, while the atomic bomb
may have ended the war,
radar won it.
While the radiation
laboratory was
the largest and most prominent
war-related activity here,
engaging nearly
4,000 individuals
at its peak in 1945, it was
not the only such effort.
As Bob has shown, work
in support of the war
took place across the
Institute, involving almost
all the academic elements.
These activities, running
under forced draft
in an atmosphere of crisis
and deep commitment,
changed MIT fundamentally
and irreversibly.
Karl Taylor Compton
put it this way
in the 1945 report
of the president.
And I quote, "the term
epoch is not customarily
used to designate so short
a period as five years,
yet in many ways the term is
appropriate to these war years.
In these five
years, the Institute
spent on its war
contracts as much money
as it had spent on
its normal activities
during the previous
80 years of existence.
This is a sobering thought.
It makes one wonder what
tremendous things could
be accomplished in peacetime if
the same energy, determination,
and resources were marshaled
to fashion a better world."
End of quote.
Now, you understand that I
had no personal experience
with the World War
II years at Tech.
When I arrived in
1950, the nation
was focused on two other
wars, one hot and one cold.
However, as I've
tried to understand
the consequences
of the war for MIT,
it has seemed to
me useful to think
about the effects of that period
as principally of three kinds.
First, the war
and the GI Bill it
produced expanded and changed,
democratized the MIT student
body.
Second, the wartime
problems presented
intellectual challenges
which were vastly different
from the knowledge base of
pre-war engineering education
and practice, thereby creating
a mandate for great change
in engineering curricula.
Third, the significant
benefits that
flowed from the
wartime partnership
between educational institutions
and the federal government
led to the creation of
peacetime partnerships
and to the evolution of
the research universities
for which MIT is a paradigm.
In the time remaining
to me this morning,
I shall briefly describe
these three effects.
First, growth and change
in the student body.
In the years just
before the war,
the number of students
at the Institute
was around 3,100, of which
about 2,400 were undergraduates
and 700 were graduate students.
Not surprisingly, the number
of matriculated students
decreased sharply
during the war years,
reaching a low of
about 1,200 in 1944-45.
Where'd we go?
There.
This starts over here
1939, runs across to 1950.
Little over 3,000 in
the pre-war years.
Dropped in '44, '45,
down still in '46,
but then up above 5,000 in
those years starting in 1947.
The enrollments never again
fell below the level of 5,000,
except for one year
during the Korean War.
More importantly
than these numbers,
these students were
sharply different
from their counterparts
of the pre-war years.
KT says it best in his report
of the president for 1945-46,
the first full academic year
after the end of the war.
I'd like that picture, please,
of Compton in slide number two.
Next one.
There we are.
These are KT's words from the
1945-46 president's report.
"If you were to
introduce yourself
to a student whom you
chance to meet while walking
through the Institute
corridors, the probability
is that he would be an
undergraduate, older by two
to four years than a pre-war
student of the same class.
He would explain to you with
courtesy and poise borne
of military experience
that he is a veteran,
and that his objective
here is to secure
a first-class
professional education as
quickly as possible.
If you were to express an
interest in his personal
situation, you might discover
that he is one of the married
veterans-- more than 30% of
the veterans are married--
and that his family
includes a youngster."
"If you inquire
about his studies,
you will find that his
attitude is mature, serious,
and hard-headed,
and his grades high.
Since the educational
expenses of the veterans
are financed largely
by the government,
applicants have
not been restricted
by financial considerations.
The students, therefore,
come from all walks of life,
and for the first time
we have a student body
for which ability, preparation,
personality, and character have
been the only requirements
for admission."
Now, it's notable that, while
20 years would pass before
the concepts of [? need-blind ?]
admissions and student aid
sufficient to meet full need
would emerge here at MIT,
KT laid out the rationale for
those ideas in his 1946 report,
at a time when this place was
much enriched by the greater
social and economic diversity
represented by the veteran
students.
Treasurer's report data
show that, for the year
1946-47 and 1947-48,
more than half
of the tuition receipts
of the Institute
originated with the
Veterans Administration.
And that fraction remained
quite high through 1952.
If Dr. John Horton
is in the audience,
there is an emergency
page for him.
Would he please
call 201-425-6937.
201-425-6937.
Dr. John Horton.
The increased number of
students at MIT in these years
required increases in
the faculty, as well,
and the count of
professors of all ranks
rose from fewer than 300 in
the immediate pre-war years
to 400 in 1947,
and to 500 by 1953.
The Institute
struggled in the years
just after the war to
find space to accommodate
the sudden increase in
educational and research
activities.
Of course, the
temporary buildings
thrown up to house the
radiation laboratory
were pressed into service.
We're going the wrong way here.
I'll get it straight
before I'm done.
One back, please.
There we are.
Building 20 is still
there on Vassar Street,
full of academic programs
and research activities.
[APPLAUSE]
I say to you, though, if you
have a particular affection
for building 20, and
if your pattern is
to return to MIT only
every five years,
go walk around today, because it
may not be there in five years.
[LAUGHTER]
Building 22, in the left
foreground of this photograph,
was converted to
a barracks, where
100 freshmen lived for periods
ranging from days to months.
It, happily, is long gone.
To meet the needs
of married veterans,
the Institute built, in
1946, with its own funds,
the village known as Westgate,
which housed 100 families.
Here in the foreground, it
was the first veterans project
undertaken by an
American college.
These changes in
the MIT student body
that resulted from the war and
the GI Bill were, I submit,
preamble to the
further democratization
of this place, which
began 20 years later,
and which is so evident today.
Now, 2/5 of the
undergraduates and a quarter
of the graduate
students are women.
African-Americans,
Hispanic-Americans,
Asian-Americans,
Native Americans,
and large numbers of foreign
citizens study at MIT.
The human face of the
Institute reflects
ever more fully the society
and the world in which we live.
I come now to the revolution
in engineering curricula.
The applications of technology
to the defense effort
led engineers into new
fields of engineering science
and technology--
microwaves, waveguides,
feedback control systems,
analog computation,
and radar technology,
to mention just a few.
Many engineers educated
in the '20s and '30s
found such topics
enormously challenging.
The underlying physical and
mathematical foundations
necessary for effective work in
these new areas were not there.
Further, the increased pace
of technology development,
driven by the war
effort, resulted
in the introduction of
much quite new technology
in the years just after the war.
The invention of the
transistor in 1948
changed everything for
electrical engineers,
as did the widespread
use of jet engines,
and the transition
to supersonic flight
for aeronautical and
mechanical engineers.
These changes in
applied technology
led the engineering faculty
at MIT and elsewhere
to undertake dramatic revisions
of programs for engineering
education, shifting the emphasis
to engineering science and more
mathematics.
At the Institute,
this revolution
was led principally
by Gordon Brown, who
served as head of the electrical
engineering department
from 1952 to 1959, and
as dean of engineering
from 1959 to 1968.
Gordon, who headed the
servomechanisms laboratory
during the war,
held strong views
about the changes necessary
in the undergraduate education
of engineers.
Out went the electrical
machinery laboratory
and the steam laboratory,
in came new core programs
emphasizing the underlying
physical and mathematical
foundations, the newly
developed technology,
and engineering design.
Any who knew Gordon
in those years
will remember that
he liked to say
the only thing constant around
here is the rate of change.
And he was a major
contributor to that change.
It is, I believe, fair to
say that the engineering
school at MIT, which was in the
vanguard in these revisions,
set the pace for engineering
education in the United States
throughout the 1950s
and 1960s, and in fact
in many other nations, as well.
Now, 40 years later, the
engineering departments
here are again looking closely
at the structure and content
of the degree
programs, and listening
to the perceived needs of the
employers of our graduates.
The recently introduced
masters of engineering programs
in the school are
one manifestation
of that effort, as was
the program called Leaders
for Manufacturing,
introduced by engineering
and Sloan a few years ago.
I come now to the third
element of the transformation,
the partnership between
universities and government.
The war clearly
demonstrated the benefits
that flowed out of government
support of research
and development,
conducted largely
by university-based people.
Vannevar Bush, an electrical
engineering graduate
of the class of 1916 at
MIT, was a central figure
both in the coordination
of wartime efforts
and in the shaping of
an ongoing relationship
between the federal government
and the universities.
Bush had served during the 1930s
as dean of engineering at MIT,
and was vice president
of the Institute
in a time in which there
was but one vice president.
And later, he was president
of the Carnegie Institution
of Washington.
Van was an advisor to six MIT
presidents, including this one.
During the war years,
Van Bush served
as Director of the Office
of Scientific Research
and Development, the
federal agency which
coordinated the forced draft
research and development
efforts undertaken to aid
in prosecution of the war.
In November 1944,
more than nine months
before the end of
the war, Bush was
asked by President
Roosevelt to consider
the nature of the
government-university
partnership in the
postwar period.
FDR's letter to Bush stated
the challenge in these terms,
and I quote.
"The Office of Scientific
Research and Development,
of which you are the director,
presents a unique experiment
of teamwork and
cooperation in coordinating
scientific research and
in applying existing
scientific knowledge
to the solutions
of the technical problems
paramount in war."
"There is no reason why
the lessons found in this
experiment cannot be profitably
employed in times of peace.
The information, the techniques,
and the research experience
developed by OSRD, and by
the thousands of scientists
in the universities and
in private industry,
should be used in the
days of peace ahead
for the improvement
of national health,
for the creation of new
enterprise, bringing new jobs,
and for the betterment of
national standards of living."
End quote.
Van Bush brought
together a panel
to undertake this
broadly stated task,
and they made their
response to President Truman
in the form of a report
dated July 5th, 1945,
entitled Science--
The Endless Frontier.
This report expressed
two priorities.
I quote again.
"First, we must have plenty
of men and women trained
in science, for
upon them depends
both the creation
of new knowledge
and its application
to practical purposes.
Second, we must
strengthen the centers
of basic research,
which are principally
the colleges, universities,
and research institutes.
These institutions
provide the environment
which is most conducive
to the creation
of new scientific
knowledge, and least
under pressure for
immediate tangible results."
End quote.
Van understood instinctively,
and expressed in Science--
The Endless Frontier, the
importance of tying together,
completely tying together
graduate education
and front-line research.
He recognized that
both prospered best
when they were done in the same
environment by the same people.
An extremely
important proposition.
Science-- The Endless
Frontier provided the basis
for ongoing federal support
in scientific research,
and for the growth and
development of the research
universities.
It led to the establishment by
the Congress of the National
Institutes of Health and the
National Science Foundation,
two agencies which are now
in the vanguard of research
and student support
in higher education.
And to the encouragement
of continued research
support by the Department of
Defense and the Atomic Energy
Agency.
It promoted the development
of policies and practices
which permitted the
reimbursement of institutions
of higher education for the
research which they undertook
on behalf of the government.
Support of university and
college-based research
took two forms, fellowships
and traineeships, in some cases
entirely portable,
awarded on the basis
of intellectual merit,
and direct support
of research programs on the
basis of contracts and grants,
including considerable
support of a highly
discretionary nature.
Bush's report set the stage for
federal patronage of research
in colleges and universities,
and for graduate education
in science and engineering.
And the support which it
produced grew steadily.
Colleges and universities
found their development
during the 1950s limited
by the scarcity of support
for facilities which their
expanded mission required.
It took another war,
one of a different kind,
to enable a new phase
in the development
of this relationship, one in
which the need for facilities
was addressed.
Before the end of
the 1940s, the shape
of the coming conflict between
the Western democracies
and the Soviet bloc
nations became evident.
In a speech at Westminster
College in Fulton, Missouri,
in 1946, Winston Churchill
described the nature
of what he called the Iron
Curtain, which divided Europe.
The Soviet attempt to starve
the Allies out of Berlin
in its blockade of all surface
transportation from the West
to the partitioned
city marked the first
of many East-West
confrontations and tests
of power, which were to
characterize the Cold
War of the next four decades.
It was soon followed
by the war in Korea,
in which a UN force, with the
United States in the vanguard,
opposed the North
Korean invaders who
were surrogates for the USSR and
the People's Republic of China.
For most of the
1950s, the leaders
and the people of
this nation assumed
that the technical and military
superiority demonstrated
during the Second
World War would prevent
any significant heating
up of the Cold War,
and would, in any case,
permit the Western democracies
to prevail.
This smug, self-congratulatory
assuredness
was shattered in October
1957, when the Soviet
Union put Sputnik, a
grapefruit-sized Earth
satellite, in orbit.
The disillusionment was enhanced
when two American efforts
to follow suit ended in
spectacular explosions
on launchpads.
Suddenly, it seemed
to many in this nation
that we were only second best
in the competition with the USSR
in space, perhaps in
Cold War weaponry,
as well, and possibly in science
and engineering education
to boot.
Within days of the
launch of Sputnik,
President Eisenhower appointed
Dr. James Rhyne Killian
Jr., then president of MIT,
as his science advisor,
and the first presidential
science advisory mechanism,
the President's Science Advisory
Committee, PSAC for short,
was formed.
Several efforts to improve
the teaching of mathematics
and science in the schools were
created, and, in due course,
the physical science study
committee curriculum,
the new math, and new versions
of biology and chemistry
appeared.
The Congress, in the National
Defense Education Act,
created and funded
programs of student aid
intended to draw
more young people
into the study of science
and engineering in college.
The sense of hazard created
by the technical achievements
of the USSR, and by a few
episodes of the Cold War,
including the erection
of the Berlin Wall
and the crisis over Soviet
nuclear missiles in Cuba,
produced an astonishing period
of growth for higher education.
Funds for sponsored research
in colleges and universities
increased by more than a factor
of five in constant dollars
during the decade from 1958 to
1968, as shown in this figure.
The ordinate here is
on a logarithmic scale,
so that exponentials
become straight lines.
And you see essentially
exponential growth
from 1958 to 1968.
The slope of that line
corresponds to a growth rate
of about 18% per year.
The support of graduate
students through fellowships
and traineeships grew strongly,
as did grant and loan programs
in support of
undergraduate students.
Most important, federal
agencies made grants
for the construction
of research facilities,
and for major
items of equipment,
which enabled the remarkable
expansion of the research
universities.
At MIT, the partnership
with the federal government
produced very rapid growth
on several dimensions.
The volume of
sponsored research,
including work done at
the Lincoln Laboratory
and the Instrumentation
Laboratory,
which became the Draper
Laboratory in 1970, as well
as on this campus, increased
in constant dollars
by a factor of almost three from
1958 to 1968, as shown here.
The top line is total federal
research and development
at MIT, about $300 million.
These are all 1994
dollars, by the way.
It seemed sensible
to me to put all
of these numbers in
current dollar terms.
1994 dollars, about 300
million total in 1958,
up to just over 700
million in 1968.
The red line shows
campus research support.
This is research
done principally
on the campus by graduate
students and faculty,
up by a larger fraction,
of course, over that time.
And the defense laboratories,
Lincoln and Instrumentation,
taken together, the blue line.
By 1970, the number of
enrolled students at MIT
had increased to 8,000,
approximately half of whom
were graduate students.
The faculty of the Institute
grew to just over 1,000.
Many academic facilities
were added to the campus,
with a peak of
research-related construction
activity in the 1960s, which saw
the construction of the Space
Center.
Here is the Space
Center on Vassar Street,
just coming out of the ground.
The physical plant, central
steam plant in the background.
And the Center for Materials
Research and Engineering,
building 13, behind
the great dome.
Occupying yet
another parking lot.
The American presence,
military presence,
in Southeast Asia, which
began early in the 1960s,
accelerated rapidly
in the administration
of President Lyndon B.
Johnson, from 1963 to 1968.
By the late 1960s,
military expenditures
were in continuous and severe
conflict with LBJ's programs
for the Great Society,
in which he envisioned
an end to poverty, homelessness,
and all avoidable human misery
in America.
That conflict, which
was intense by 1968,
led to an abrupt
change in the growth
of federal support of higher
education in that year,
as is evident here.
We got it upside
down, I'm afraid.
[LAUGHTER]
There we are.
This, again, logarithmic
scale on the ordinate.
1954 the first
year, over to 1994.
40 years of federal support
of university-based research.
This is the total federal
support of all universities
in the United States.
And again, it's
constant 1994 dollars.
You see here this period
of 15 or so years' duration
of very rapid growth,
double-digit growth,
exponential growth
during that period,
an abrupt change in
1969, 1970, essentially
flat during the Nixon and into
the Carter administration,
turning up a little at the
beginning of the Reagan
administration, growing
here again exponentially,
but at a much lower rate, 6%
or 7% a year, and then flat
or turning down a little
in these most recent years.
While support was flat in
real terms in the 1970s,
college and university-based
research enterprise
continued to grow in
size and complexity.
There was no resumption of
real growth in federal support
or research in colleges
and universities
until early in the
Reagan administration,
and growth from 1983
to 1989 was about 7%
per year, which has not been
matched in these recent years.
The conflict in
federal priorities
not only reversed the trend of
federal support of research,
they also set the
economy of the nation
on the course of steadily
growing inflation.
This pattern, which lasted
until the early 1980s,
produced cost pressures on
colleges and universities
which were intense, and
which led to a decade or more
of large increases
in tuitions and fees.
These pressures, coupled
with a steady decline
in real terms of federal
support for student aid,
has led to the
present severe demand
for the use of institutional
discretionary funds
in support of scholarships.
Now, clearly the interval
from 1950 to 1968
reflected a period of
extraordinary growth
not approached in
the decades since.
Many in the research
university community
think of the 1960s as the
golden years, a decade in which
the partnership between the
federal government and higher
education achieved a
real rate of growth
of research support,
which, while obviously not
sustainable over the long
term, might be regarded
as a standard against
which other efforts could
be measured.
Many informed
persons in government
regard this decade of remarkable
growth as the exception,
rather than any kind of
rule, as a unique interval
which resulted from the sense
of unlimited possibilities
that was so characteristic
of the 1950s and early 1960s.
They regard it as an aberration
unlikely ever to occur again.
With the end of the Cold War,
and the threats and unifying
theme it presented, with the
disintegration of the Soviet
Union, and now with a new
Congress in Washington,
we are seeing the beginnings of
a conflict of a different kind,
a war on the federal deficit.
And the associated
conflicts and reassessment
of national priorities
will have consequences
for higher education,
which will be, I believe,
fully as significant as the
consequences of World War
II and the Cold War.
While my purpose
in these remarks
has been to sketch out the
several dimensions of what
has been a transformation in
the character and scale of MIT,
a transformation over
these last 50 years
that was a consequence of
World War II and the Cold War,
which followed
hard on its heels.
With the Cold War ended,
we face security threats
of very different kinds--
small-scale, increasingly
violent conflicts,
as in the former
Yugoslavia, growing gaps
between the haves
and the have nots
of the world, and of
this nation, terrorism,
and the nightmare of potential
nuclear weapons proliferation.
None of these threats
appears to our government
to require or to justify
the support of education
or university-based
research, which was
so evident during the Cold War.
And the struggle to reshape the
federal budget, a struggle so
evident in these last
weeks, seems all too likely
to force dramatic changes
in support of education
and basic research.
35 years ago, Glenn Seaborg
and his colleagues on PSAC,
the President's Science Advisory
Committee, put it this way,
in a report entitled Scientific
Progress, the Universities
and the Federal Government.
And I quote, "whether
the quantity and quality
of basic research and graduate
education in the United States
will be adequate or
inadequate depends primarily
on the government of
the United States.
From this responsibility,
the federal government
has no escape.
Either it will find the
policies and the resources which
permit our universities
to flourish
and their duties to be
adequately discharged,
or no one will."
"The federal government at
times seems to those of us
in universities to be a fickle,
untrustworthy, unreliable,
and unsympathetic partner,
set on regarding higher
education as just one more
special interest group,
and given to construing the
research partnership as similar
in nature to the procurement
of combat boots or Jeeps.
And I know, because government
officials and members
of Congress have
from time to time
explained it quite
forcefully to me,
that the universities
seem at times
to be arrogant,
imperfect, unreasonably
demanding entities, remarkably
insensitive to political and
fiscal realities."
"And there's much truth
in both perspectives.
Nevertheless, the partnership is
vital to the national welfare,
and its accomplishments
over the past five decades
have been both extraordinary
in scope and of great benefit
to the nation.
The productivity
of the relationship
is evident in all
those areas anticipated
in 1944 by President Roosevelt
in his charge to Van Bush--
improved health, new
industries and new jobs,
and improvements in
living standards."
As Seaborg put it in
that same report in 1960,
with all their
irritating faults,
universities are essential
agencies of our national hopes,
and they must be
treated accordingly.
The federal government,
with all its contradictions,
surprises, and persistent myopia
about the longer term future
is the sine qua non for the
universities and colleges.
Making the partnership
work better
is in the national interest,
and deserves our unstinting,
steadily applied best efforts,
for on that partnership depends
the well-being of
higher education
and the nation it serves
in the next century.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
I now invite Lester
Thurow to the lectern.
[APPLAUSE]
THUROW: If you think
about a major war,
what a major war does
is shake the system.
And it shakes the system in one
fundamental sociological way.
And that is people are
willing to do things
that they're not willing to
do in any other circumstance.
And if you look at
World War II, it's
important to put it
together with the fact
that, in the 1930s
and the 1940s,
the American social
system was grievously
shocked by two earthquakes.
The first, of course,
was the Great Depression,
and the second was World War II.
And those two events did not
accelerate economic change,
although they may
have done that,
and accelerate social
change, although they
may have done that.
They set the system off in a
completely different direction.
And it's important, if you look
at the economics of wartime
and what happens
afterwards, is people never
go back to the status quo ante.
19 million women went to
work, as Doris mentioned.
At the end of the war, they
went back a little bit,
but very quickly the
employment of females
was back up to 19 million.
And today, if you go to
America's law schools
and medical schools, you
will find that more than half
of the students are female.
That simply would
not have happened
without the double shake of the
Great Depression and World War
II.
It's also important to remember
that, in the Great Depression,
Karl Marx came very
close to being correct.
We could be here
today in a world
where capitalism does not exist.
And it would be
very easy to happen.
You remember that he predicted
that capitalism would collapse
in a great financial crisis.
He was right.
Capitalism did collapse
in 1929 to 1932.
And in December 1941,
when World War II
began for the United
States, essentially
there was one and a half
capitalist countries
left in the world, the United
States and a gravely weakened,
about to be defeated
Great Britain.
Everybody else was a colony,
fascist, or communist.
And they were that
for very good reasons.
In 1939, there was not a
single shred of evidence
that the United States would be
able to recover from the Great
Depression.
As Doris mentioned,
the unemployment rate
was still 17%, and there
was no recovery light
at the end of the tunnel.
And the country was
becoming radicalized.
The conservatives didn't like
it that Franklin Roosevelt
was using the phrase "the
malefactors of great wealth."
The little town that I
lived in in Montana in 1937
elected a communist
city government,
and they were not alone.
It was a mining community.
The radicals of the
wobblies were still there.
With a few missteps in the
1930s and after World War II,
we could be living in a
very different world today.
And if you say, what did the
Great Depression and World War
II do for us, it gave us a
completely different vision
of what was important
and what was unimportant.
In 1932, at the end of
the Hoover administration,
the then head of the
Federal Reserve Board,
appointed by Mr.
Hoover, stood up
and, if you can imagine this, in
1932, when unemployment was 25%
and prices were
falling by 10%, said
the most important problem in
America is fighting inflation.
Think about that.
Because the problem is,
in normal circumstance,
the past, and the
problems of the past,
have a lock on the
present and the future.
And what happens in wartime
is that lock is broken.
And then the question is
what direction do we go.
And that's the
place where I think
Roosevelt and Churchill played
a remarkable role, because they
didn't go with the flow,
they created the flow.
Somebody once remarked,
how many times
in the morning when
you woke up do you
think that President Truman,
the first thing he did
was consult a
public opinion poll?
The answer is Harry
Truman never did that.
[APPLAUSE]
Because that's what
leadership's all about.
And of course, the problem
in the modern world
is every politician has
an easy alternative.
Public opinion polls are so
good that you can basically
figure out where the
public parade is going,
jump to the front of it,
and look like a leader, when
in fact you're a follower.
But at this period of time,
partly because of the nature
of the people leading
our countries,
and partly because the public
opinion polls were not so good,
you had to create the parade.
Otherwise, it would
never be behind you.
You couldn't find it.
And the question is, what
kind of a parade was created?
One of the interesting
things, of course,
is we think of the United
States as a middle class nation.
It wasn't a middle class
nation in 1936, '37, '38.
It was a nation divided
into very poor people
and very rich people.
And it's important
to remember that.
One of the things that
was done in World War II,
you remember that we had
wage and price controls.
The people running
wage and price controls
had to set wages.
What did they do?
They felt, correctly, that,
since we were fighting
in a war, and you were asking
12 million people to take
the risk of dying, that was
inherently an egalitarian
problem, and that therefore
they would very severely narrow
wage differentials
as they were setting
wages and prices in their
wage and price controls.
And they did that.
And the interesting thing about
those narrow wage differentials
is, first of all, that
they maintained themselves
after World War II.
And secondly, if anything, they
contributed to productivity,
as opposed to subtracting
from productivity,
because before the war everybody
would have said, if you make
wages that equal, everybody
will quit working.
In fact, they worked
harder, they invested more
in themselves, and they
became a better workforce
with a more egalitarian wage
structure, rather than a worse
workforce.
Second thing we did is we said
that capitalism has a defect.
We started to practice
Keynesian economics,
because what we learned at
the beginning of World War II
is, if you have a
Great Depression
and the government
simply goes out
and pushes demand
into the system,
it is, in fact, possible
to bring everybody back
to employment.
And at the peak of
World War II, instead
of having 25% of the population
unemployed, we had less than 1%
of the population unemployed.
We also learned in World
War II that science pays.
That's what the
atomic bomb taught us.
Long-run research pays
off, and it pays off
in a very simple way.
Harry Truman was
told that a million
people would be casualties
if the Japanese islands were
invaded.
In fact, with technology,
none of those deaths
were necessary on
the American side.
Science, in some sense,
became the black box
out of which good things came.
And our support for science
came out of that effort,
because it was
probably true, in 1939,
if you were told as a scientist
that you had to give up
your subscription to the German
Physical Review or the American
Physical Review, you would
have given up your subscription
to the American Physical Review,
because in the '20s and '30s,
the leader of world
science was not,
in fact, the United States.
It was Germany.
That's where graduate
students went
to study if you
were really smart,
not coming to the United States.
We also learned in
World War II that it
was possible to engineer
a rapidly growing economy.
Growth was the goal.
And we learned something
that has a double message.
We learned you can collect
taxes and the world
doesn't fall apart, because
it's important to remember
that the tax system was
built in World War II.
In the 1930s, the maximum
tax rate in the United States
was 10%, and very
few people paid it.
During World War II, the
maximum tax rate was 90%,
and lots of people paid it, and
the world didn't fall apart.
And what that allowed
us to do after the war
was build the social
welfare state,
which I'll come back
and talk to in a moment.
So if you think
of the big picture
that we learned in
World War II, we
learned that you could
make a very different world
work than the world
we had in the 1920s.
And we also came out
of that experience,
of course, if you had been
running the federal government
in 1945, as the war was winding
down, what was your big worry?
The Great Depression was
going to start again,
because that was a real fear
inside the American government
in 1945, that the war would
simply be a blip in the United
States economy, and would
promptly collapse immediately
after the war was over.
Now, if you look at the vision
we had after World War II,
it is a vision that came
out of World War II.
And in some sense,
the last 50 years
is, if you'd like to think of
it, the half life of World War
II.
It's a vision that we lived on.
And as I shall point
out in a few minutes,
it's a vision which
has now dissolved,
and we're going to be asked
to create a new division.
What was that
vision made out of?
First of all, the vision for
the post World War II economy
was made out of the experience
in World War II is we can
and we will run a full
employment economy.
Government will not
allow the economy
to slide into a Great Depression
with a 25% unemployment
rate and financial collapses.
And if you look at
the recessions that
occurred after World
War II until we
get into the 1990s,
each and every time
you see government
running to the rescue.
These same thing's true with
incipient financial crises.
The stock market crash of 1987
was not allowed to continue.
In the foreign policy,
area we essentially shifted
from the fascists
to the communists,
and we instituted a
policy of containment.
We remembered Munich.
We remembered that you
have to contain aggressors.
At the end of World
War II, you remember
that people sat around expecting
economic growth to occur
and capitalism to
reestablish itself
in countries like France,
Germany, Great Britain, where
either it had been
severely weakened
or it had not established--
had been run out of business
by the fascists earlier.
It didn't happen.
In 1948, three years after
the war was over in Europe,
there was no recovery
in France, there
was no recovery in Germany,
and the British economy
was, in fact, an
incipient collapse.
And it was the
incipient collapse
of the British economy
that led to the formation
of the Marshall Plan, of putting
capitalism back together again,
because we came
to the conclusion
that it wouldn't
happen automatically
by spontaneous combustion.
Now, today, Americans, in
real dollar terms per capita,
are two and a half times as
wealthy as they were in 1948.
But think about what we
were willing to do in 1948.
In 1948, we put 3%
of the American GNP
into the Marshall Plan.
In today's dollars,
that would mean
giving foreign aid of more
than $200 billion a year.
What do you think we
Americans actually
do in terms of economic
foreign aid today?
Less than $7 billion.
For all practical
purposes, nothing.
We give $8 or $9 billion worth
of military aid, but almost
no economic foreign aid.
World War II led to the end
of the colonial empires.
When I was a student in the
'40s and '50s in school,
they still had the
old maps where,
other than Europe
and North America,
everything was
either green or red--
red if you were in
the British Empire,
green if you were in
the French Empire.
If it hadn't been
for World War II,
those empires might
be there today.
They certainly would have lasted
a much longer period of time.
It's interesting,
the whole concept
that poor people can get rich
came out of World War II.
The word foreign aid
never left anybody's lips
before World War II, because
the purpose of the Third World
was to make the
First World rich.
India was supposed to make
Britain rich, not vice versa.
Now, there's a big
argument among historians
about whether the British
put more money into India
or took more money out
of India, but there
is no argument about what the
British were trying to do.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
The purpose was to take
Third World countries
and use them to
make yourself rich.
And the whole concept that
everybody in the world
could, in fact, become rich, and
that the rich people might even
help them a little
bit to become rich
was something that came
out of this period of time.
The same thing is true of
the social welfare state.
And whatever its
current problems
is, what the social
welfare state basically
said is, when you're
sick, when you're old,
when you're unemployed,
you will not
be thrown off the ship of state.
You will be allowed to live.
Because there were people prior
to this time, and people now,
who are basically
practicing what
is called survival of
the fittest capitalism.
And I'll remind you
a bit of history.
Darwin did not invent the
phrase survival of the fittest.
It was invented by a
19th century economist
by the name of
Spencer, who believed
it was the duty of
the economically fit
to drive the economically
unfit into starvation
and out of the economy.
Spencer is having
a revival today,
but he was not popular in
the 1940s and the 1950s,
because people remembered
the '30s and the '40s,
and they remembered that too
many people would be thrown off
the ship when they became
old, when they became sick,
when they became unemployed.
We also had a decision to make
at the time of the Marshall
Plan.
Does the United States want to
retreat back into isolationism,
or does the United States want
to create a world economy.
Partly because of the
challenge of the Soviet Union,
where there was a world
vision of communism conquering
the world, the United States was
forced to become international.
And in 1944, before the World
War was over, up here north
in Bretton Woods,
New Hampshire we
created the GATT
Bretton Woods system,
which is the system we've
lived with for the last 50
years in the world.
That was a system which said
that the great open market
for the world would
be the United States.
And every single
country in the world
that's become rich
in the last 50 years
has gone through
a period of time
when at least half their exports
came to the United States.
That was true of Europe in
the '50s, Japan in the '60s,
and in the '80s that was
true of Korea, Taiwan, Hong
Kong, Singapore,
and in the '90s it's
true of communist
China, the PRC.
We would be the
locomotive for the world.
If the world economy
slowed down and threatened
to slip into a recession,
it was our responsibility
to engineer a recovery.
We would be the
manager for the system,
taking responsibility
to give it leadership.
One of the problems,
of course, with this
is we sold a whole set of
things as anticommunism,
and then the question
is, do you buy them
when communism goes away?
One of the things we
sold as anticommunism
was basically creating
the middle class.
The GI Bill was central in
creating the middle class.
As I mentioned, there was no
middle class in the 1930s.
The wage and price
controls of World
War II and setting a
new structure of wages
was essential in committing
the middle class.
And with a combination
of unionization
and social pressure,
we basically
created what I would
call the post World War
II social contract between
business and labor.
And what that
social contract said
is, if you're running a
company, and your profits go up
and your sales go up, you
will share some of that gain
with your employees.
That's what created
the middle class.
We also sold investment
as anticommunism.
It's important to remember
that the interstate highway
system wasn't sold
as a highway system,
it was sold as a
system necessary
because we were going
to move mobile missiles
around the United States,
and all the bridges
had to be high enough to get
the missile trucks under them.
And if you go back and read the
original legislation in 1957,
the words national
defense appear in the act
for the interstate highways.
It was already mentioned the
National Defense Education Act.
Many of us who got
our PhDs in the 1960s
got them on the National
Defense Education Act.
The space program, one of
the most exciting things
human beings have
ever done, had to be
justified as a military
race with the Russians.
And we probably wouldn't
have played in that race
unless we thought it
was a military race
with the Russians.
We sold internationalism
as anticommunism.
That was why it was
correct for Americans
to intervene
elsewhere in the world
to try and preserve democracy
and keep communism out.
And so if you look
at World War II,
I would argue to you that it
had the most profound effects
on the American social
and economic system,
and it had a half life of about
50 years, where we are today.
Because where we are
today, of course,
is with the implosion of
the Soviet Union in 1991,
and the fall of the
Berlin Wall in 1989,
is all of the anchor
points have gone.
There is no enemy out there.
The United States is
threatened by no one.
There is no military
threat to us.
And the question is, in
this brand-new world,
what is our vision, and
what do we want to do?
The one third of
humanity who used
to live in the communist
world has basically
said we want to join you.
And of course, the problem
is that, when they join us,
it isn't just they that
will have to change,
it is partly we who
will have to change.
In many parts of the world,
it's important to understand,
in the post World War II,
borders move very seldom,
because the one thing
America and the Soviet Union
could agree on is never move
a border between any two
countries, because it was too
likely that one was our ally,
the other was
their ally, whoever
would lose would call
his big brother to help,
and there was this fear
that the missiles would
fly from Moscow to Washington
if you moved a border in Africa.
In most of human
history, borders move.
And we're entering
an era where borders
are going to move everywhere.
15 countries in the
old Soviet Union,
seven countries in
the old Yugoslavia,
two countries in the
old Czechoslovakia.
Every border in Africa
is going to move,
because they're simply where the
British and French armies met
in the colonial
era, and they make
no sense in terms of
economics, no sense in terms
of ethnic or language results.
India is a big country,
which of course has never
been one country,
except when conquered
by an outsider invader,
the Moguls or the British.
And it's already split
into three countries
and threatening to
split into more.
And even north of our
border, we may end up
with two countries, Quebec
and the rest of Canada.
We have a very simple problem.
The problem is the post
World War II period is over.
The impetus of World
War II is over.
The question is, what is
our vision for the future,
and can we march
to get that vision?
When I was dean of
the management school,
I always used to
tell our students
that it's very easy to
be a manager in a crisis,
because it's in a crisis
it's obvious you've
got to do something.
It's not obvious
what you have to do,
but that's usually pretty
easy to figure out.
The hard thing is to persuade
people to do something.
And the crisis does it for you.
The problem at the moment
is there is no crisis.
The question is,
what is the vision?
And the answer is we don't
know what the vision is.
And that's our
problem, of course,
in Bosnia, Rwanda,
Somalia, and lots
of other places in the world.
Does this call for
an American response
and American leadership,
or does it not
call for an American response
and American leadership?
And you can't
answer that question
until you know
what the vision is.
The same thing is true when
you come to American science
policy.
What's the vision?
Does America want to be
the world's science leader,
or does it not want to be
the world's science leader?
What are the benefits and the
costs of those two options?
And in some sense, I
would argue that today's
political leadership has
a much more tough task
than those in the
1930s and the 1940s,
because there is no crisis.
Can we change without
a crisis, and can we
create that new vision
without a crisis?
And that's what we're
going to be tested on
in the next 10 to 15 years.
At the height of
imperial Rome, one
of the people who lived
in the Roman Empire
but was not a Roman said the
following about the Romans.
"The Romans are not the
smartest in the world.
The Greeks are smarter.
The Romans are not the
most numerous in the world.
The Spanish are more numerous.
The Romans are
not the strongest.
The Germans are stronger."
"The Romans are
not the wealthiest.
The North Africans
are wealthier.
The Romans have not a single
piece of military equipment
that every army in that
world doesn't also have.
The Romans have one
and only one virtue--
they have a vision, and the
ability to march toward it."
The question is, do we have
a vision and the ability
to march toward it?
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
VEST: Not only do I have
the unenviable task of being
sandwiched between that least
dismal of all economists
and a flyby of World War II
aircraft, which, by the way,
has been postponed a few
minutes, so don't fear,
but I also have
the uncanny feeling
that Dr. Goodwin
has been listening
in to the dinner conversation
at the Vest household.
Males driving endlessly around
for fear of asking directions?
Imagine that.
[LAUGHTER]
Technology Day is
traditionally a showcase
for cutting-edge work of this
university, a great institution
dedicated to shaping the future.
This morning,
however, you have been
invited to look back, to think
about the intersection of MIT
with the world's
most cataclysmic war,
and to ponder the reverberations
of that [? collision ?]
over the past half century.
This wide-angle
focus, this attention
to the lessons of history
could not be more timely,
as has just been pointed out.
The years represented by the
classes of 1945 and of 1970
were periods when universities
were integral players
in a tumultuous world
and national events
that modified our agenda
and transformed our nature.
It appears to me that the
closing years of this century
will be another such
era, a time when
remaining aloof from
the public arena
will be neither
appropriate nor possible.
The relationship between
the American people
and their government
is changing.
Partnerships of every
kind between branches
of the federal government
and involved constituencies
are coming under
the budgetary axe.
And that most certainly includes
our research universities.
It's ironic that the threat
to our research effort
and to our ability to
provide affordable education
to an undiminished
stream of gifted students
comes at a time when
tremendous breakthroughs are
within grasp in countless areas
of science and technology.
The spirit of the
Radiation Lab is not dead.
It is the thought
of opportunities
that may be missed
that fuels our concern.
The parties in power in the
White House and on Capitol Hill
have changed many times
since World War II.
The concern of the
university community
is not so much which
party holds the reins,
but whether Washington
decision-makers have
the political will
and insight to serve
society's long-term need for
new knowledge, new technologies,
and, above all, for superbly
educated young men and women.
So my message this
morning will be twofold,
that MIT's future can be just
as exciting and adventurous
as in the past, and that real
and immediate threats could
cause us to fall far short.
First, let's look at some
indicators of excellence.
MIT continues to recruit the
most gifted and committed
young faculty.
Their work is of the first rank.
They've transformed our
knowledge of the oceans,
created the first
self-replicating synthetic
molecule, observed the wave
function of a single atom,
gained deep insight into the
pervasive tumor suppressor gene
notated P53, and created
the worldwide web
that has electronically
connected people
and information throughout
the world in a simply
astounding manner.
The excitement of such work
informs their teaching,
and it certainly
engages their students,
which is not to say that we
have achieved all our goals
with respect to the faculty.
We still have difficulty
hiring the numbers of women
and minority faculty
that we need to better
reflect and serve
a changing America,
and our efforts to support
a greater portion of faculty
salaries from General
Institute funds
so that they are less dependent
on the fluctuating research
support still involve
a lot of heavy lifting
in the fundraising arena.
The second indicator of
our promise, of course,
is the most important,
namely our students.
Applications for admission
to our undergraduate programs
have increased by 25%
during the last two years.
The attraction of
an MIT education
has never been greater.
In fact, we were caught
off-guard by a sudden increase
in the fraction of
students admitted
to this year's freshman class
who've accepted our offer.
Response is so great,
we are likely to end up
with a bit of crowding in
our dormitories in the fall.
But that's a high-class problem.
And the third
indicator is the spirit
of innovation and
inventiveness that permeates
our academic programs.
We have led the nation,
as Paul pointed out,
in designing new five-year
integrated bachelor, masters
engineering curricula,
thereby defining
a new master of
engineering degree,
as the first professional
engineering degree.
The Sloan School's
MBA curriculum
has been fundamentally
restructured, restructured
for a new era of global,
technologically intensive
business organizations.
Implementations will
begin this September
of a radical new
pedagogical approach
to undergraduate education
in mechanical engineering.
We've just established
molecular and cell biology
as a core degree requirement,
and the faculty recently
approved our first truly
interdisciplinary minor
program, one in
biomedical engineering.
New information technology,
such as computer simulation,
interactive CD-ROMs, hypertext
educational materials,
and instructional uses
of the worldwide web
are being applied in subjects
ranging from language
learning to astronomy.
If MIT is to remain a
world-class institution,
this inventiveness,
intellectual leadership,
and absolute excellence
are necessary conditions,
but they are no longer
sufficient ones.
The present threat
to the viability
of our national research
effort did not suddenly
burst upon the
scene last November.
For the last decade,
as Paul has discussed,
forces have been chipping away
at the partnership created
by Vannevar Bush.
The process was accelerated by
the end of the Cold War, whose
military needs and culture
of superpower competition
had created a climate of
support for advanced education
and for research.
We won a cold peace, but the
supportive climate for research
universities has eroded.
And then, on the economic
front, global competition
hit us like a ton of bricks.
In a span of 50 years,
the United States
has moved from producing
more than half the world's
gross domestic product to
producing just about 20%.
The drop was as much a
blow to the national psyche
as it was to the
national balance sheet.
There were many factors
behind the problems
in American industry.
The university
certainly must accept
their share of the blame.
In our academic
programs, we forgot
to pay enough attention to
process, to manufacturing,
to improving product quality,
to systems perspectives.
Our engineering schools
grew too distant
from the realities of
industrial practice.
Our management schools
forgot to pay attention
to production, and to the
understanding of customers.
At the same time, our
costs and our tuitions
were growing out of control.
This year, we began
moving aggressively
to improve our own customer
service, if you will,
and to begin to re-engineer
ourselves into a leaner, more
modern enterprise.
But we were too long getting
off the starting blocks.
Outside our walls, more
trouble was brewing.
As the economy
became stressed, we
witnessed the development
of a populist distrust
of institutions and groups
that aspired to excellence.
Elite became a pejorative term.
Gone was the spirit
that infused the nation
in the aftermath of
Sputnik, and that sense
that we will not be outdone.
Communities that once were proud
of their educational systems
dumped society's
problems at the feet
of their ill-prepared teachers
and shamelessly sliced
into the muscle and
bone of school budgets,
as aging populations turned
their back on the young.
Politicians found they
could make headlines
by attacking the country's most
distinguished universities.
Any one of these
changes alone would
have created a degree
of difficulty for us,
and any one of them
could be handled
without doing major damage
to our system of research
universities.
The real difficulty stems
from the cumulative effect
this damaging cascade of
policy and budgetary change.
But beyond financial matters,
this darkening climate
has spawned three
disastrous policy errors
that threaten our nation's
continuing achievement
in science and technology.
The first is an inaccurate,
unhelpful, and somewhat
partisan categorization of
research as basic, on one hand,
or applied or strategic on
the other, and the setting up
of an adversarial relationship
among these categories.
Second is the separation of the
goals of research and education
in university funding,
and third is a failure
to recognize research
funding as an investment.
Each of these
errors has a history
of accumulated political
baggage, and a set
of disturbing consequences.
Early in the Clinton
administration,
the federal government
was caught up
in a debate about what was
called strategic research.
The term referred to
projects which had clearly
foreseeable commercial value.
Its supporters in
Congress believed
that the nation's
research establishment
had a responsibility to provide
direct aid to industries
that were being clobbered in
the international marketplace.
A number of funding
agencies dramatically
shifted their focus
to proposals that
involved industrial partners,
together with universities
that might have a rapid
commercial payoff.
But only two years later, just
two years later, the pendulum
is at the other
end of its swing.
Many of the most powerful
members of the House
now declare that
the proper function
of the federal government is
only to fund basic university
research.
They see things called applied
research as the responsibility
of industry alone.
Collaboration between
corporations, government,
and universities suddenly
is being discouraged.
There is an implicit threat
to education and research
in the field of engineering
in all of this discussion.
What money is left in
the research budget
is to be focused on more
fundamental science, which,
though of course
absolutely essential,
should not be the entire
portfolio of any nation that
desires a vibrant future.
What's wrong with this picture?
For one thing, it's
predicated on the notion
that research enterprises can
be turned around on a dime.
Today we make better
toasters, tomorrow we
decode the human genome.
I don't need to belabor
for this audience
how absurd this idea is.
Science, technology, and
advanced education cannot be
turned on and off at will, nor
can they undergo major changes
of direction every two years.
Research and development
is a continuum, of course.
Indeed, research, development,
and product commercialization
is now a very different
process than it once was.
Its nonlinear
workings will not be
enhanced by artificial
partitioning of research,
especially when our parallel
objective is educating
scientists, engineers,
and managers
who have the integrated
perspective needed
for the next century.
Now, this leads me to
the second, and really
most fundamental, policy
error, one that truly could
sabotage our future, I believe.
And that's the separation
of education and research
in federal funding policy.
Preparing the next generations
of scientists and engineers
has long been a central feature
of the American research
university.
As Paul so eloquently
pointed out,
Vannevar Bush
envisioned a system
in which every dollar invested
in university research
did double duty.
It met the scientific or
technical goals of the project,
and it supported the education
of our graduate students.
Bush's vision and policy
was spectacularly successful
at MIT.
The graduate enrollment
grew from 1,600
in 1950 to 5,300 this year.
Under this policy,
the involvement
of graduate students, and indeed
of undergraduates, in research
has become a defining element of
MIT's institutional excellence.
And yet, since the late
1980s, the government
has been withdrawing from
its long-term commitment
to pay the full costs
of research, which
include those expenses
incurred by graduate research
assistants.
The size of federally
funded graduate stipends,
and even of prestigious
fellowships,
has dropped below any pretense
of covering the real costs
of graduate support.
Just this last
week, the director
of the National
Institutes of Health
said flatly that NIH is about
research, not about education.
The view now holding
sway in Washington
that the country's
requirement for new knowledge
can be met over
time by providing
only the cost of
current projects
is myopic in the extreme.
What could be more
efficient and more
cost-effective than the double
value of research and education
that can be credited to
each federal dollar spent
in an American
research university.
Continuing to talk about
the value of research
while making
inadequate provisions
for graduate education
simply amounts
to eating our seed corn.
The third policy error I see
is the increasing tendency
to define research and
development as a cost.
Research is not a cost.
It's an investment.
It's an investment with a
remarkable financial return,
even beyond its payoff
in human resources.
Even the General
Accounting Office,
after reviewing the modest
literature of the subject,
agrees that the annual return on
federal investment in research
and development is of
the order of 25% to 50%.
Michael Dertouzos, head of our
laboratory for computer science
here at MIT, makes a
very persuasive case,
that we have realized a
3,000% return to America
on the federal investment in
computer science and technology
of $5 billion over
the last 30 years.
A look at the federal
budget proposals
that are emerging
from the Congress
and from the administration
show little appreciation
for facts like this.
What are we to do about this
dramatic change in our climate?
One thing we cannot do is to sit
by waiting for our fate to be
decided.
More than at any time
since World War II,
my colleagues in the
faculty and staff and I
are working to make our
case in Washington, our case
that research universities in
general, and MIT in particular,
represent not a drain
on the national purse,
but an investment in the
nation's future well-being.
It is not enough for us
to just declare our value
to the nation, however.
We of course have
to demonstrate it.
We are speaking in
every possible forum
about the current research
at MIT, and about the promise
that it holds.
We need your help in delivering
and demonstrating this message.
It's up to us, to
all of us, working
with our colleagues
in other universities,
the national associations,
and in business and industry
to communicate with our
legislators, with the press,
and with the public at large.
We must persuade them
that knowledge, knowledge
and a population skilled
in its creative use,
are America's most important
resources for the 21st century.
Members of Congress
still listen most closely
to their own constituents.
Talk to them personally.
With your help, MIT and the
nation's other leading public
and private research
universities
will continue their tradition
of creativity and leadership
and service to our society.
The late 1990s will be a time
of reinvention and redefinition
of the research university,
for all the reasons
that Lester has pointed out.
I'm confident that
we will emerge
from this troubled time
rededicated to serving
our nation and our world.
I'm not pleading
for the status quo.
Rather, I challenge you,
as alumni and alumnae,
and I challenge our
federal government,
and especially I
challenge our industries
to join with us
in a reinvigorated
and redefined partnership.
This partnership must
establish a new national R&D
system and a new national
innovation system
to meet the challenges of the
coming economic competition.
The next round, I
believe, will be
based on excellence in
design and innovation,
and on successfully
addressing broader
social and environmental
issues, just as the competition
of this last decade
required us to learn
new ways of manufacturing
at low cost,
high quality, and decreased
product cycle times.
So let us affix our seals
to a new social contract
for education and the
advancement of human knowledge
and capability.
Through this new partnership,
with your guidance
and your financial
support, MIT will
continue leading the revolution
in molecular biology,
and advance the promise
of biotechnology.
We will come to understand the
workings of the human brain
and the nature of intelligence,
of learning, of memory.
We will bring the
MIT quality of mind
to assessing and ameliorating
the impact of humankind
on the Earth's environment.
We will secure the advances
of computers, communication
technology, and the
information marketplace
for the social good.
We will combine the aesthetic,
the humane, and the technical
in the design of the
physical environment
and the creation of
more livable cities.
We will better understand
organizations and businesses,
and how to make
them more effective
in building vital and
sustainable 21st century
economies.
And we will enrich
the liberal, visual,
and performing arts
that, in large measure,
define what it is to be human.
In sum, with your help, and
with a new partnership secured,
we can be confident that
education and research at MIT
will contribute to our
nation and to the world
a future that is more secure,
prosperous, and exciting
than any we have known.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
And now, I have the pleasure
to invite all of you
to step outside for an
event I'm sure you're
anticipating, possibly after
a rapid stop at the restroom.
And that will be the flyby
of six vintage World War
II airplanes.
They will be led
by a B-25 similar
to the one flown by MIT's
own general Jimmy Doolittle.
The planes will fly
down the Charles River,
circle over Boston
Harbor, and then
return back up the Charles.
This event is not a celebration
of military hardware,
even of antique
military hardware.
Rather, it is a tribute.
It is intended to be a
tribute to all the members
of this community who have
given their lives in service
to their country.
We've been told that the
best view of the aircraft
will be from the grassy
area between the auditorium
and the parking lot.
Between the auditorium
and the parking lot,
or also from the
parking lot itself.
Now, after the planes
have completed their loop
over the Charles, please adjourn
to the Johnson Athletic Center.
I remind you that serving
lunch to 1,200 people
is a task requiring an
almost military organization,
although I'm sure
the veterans among us
will attest that the food is
hopefully a little better here.
Your cooperation by being
in your places somewhere
around 12:45 when
lunch service begins
will be much appreciated.
My understanding is
that the flyby now
is scheduled for
12:20, so we have
time to make our way orderly
out and get in position.
Thank you again very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- And here they come.
I see airplanes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- And the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
remembers World War
II 50 years later.
Stay with us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- This is New
England Cable News.
- It was a day back in
time, some 50 years in time,
yesterday in Boston.
Eight World War II aircraft
flew over the campus
of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
New England Cable News
reporter Tom Melville
has the story of the
commemoration of MIT's war
effort half a century later.
- At Hanscom Field in
Lincoln, Massachusetts,
a worker fueled up a
sparkling collection
of American technology
from World War II.
Engines revved,
and then the planes
roared into the sky over eastern
Massachusetts for a flight
back in time, a flight
to honor the World War II
efforts of the students and
faculty of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
148 MIT alumni died serving the
United States in World War II.
This flight of eight World
War II planes in formation
remembered them.
As the formation passed
over MIT's Cambridge campus,
hundreds of alumni
gathered on the ground,
looked up, and remembered
their classmates.
- This is a shining moment
for MIT, and in commemoration
of all those men who
gave their lives,
and in commemoration of the
men like Frank Reintjes here.
- Professor Frank Reintjes
stayed on the ground.
During World War II,
he stayed at home.
But he and others at MIT helped
win the war for the Allies.
Reintjes taught at the MIT
Radar School from 1943 to 1946.
- We trained 3,000 Navy
officers, Air Corps officers
and men, and Signal
Corps officers and men.
- Radar technology
developed at MIT
helped the United
States and its allies.
- Radar, as operated
by the British,
was vital to the
protection of London,
because they could see German
aircraft rising on the mainland
long before these were visible.
- The flight, for those who
flew it and those who watched,
highlighted MIT's role in
the development of a number
of wartime technologies.
- During World War
II, MIT was involved
in several new technologies, and
was very critical to the war.
The radar development,
which allowed
the bombing to be taking
place through smoke and fog
and clouds, and also
materials technology that
ultimately resulted in the
jet engine turbine blades.
- MIT also developed
the Draper gun sight,
which allowed aircraft-mounted
guns to hit moving targets,
enemy aircraft.
B-25 bombers used the sights.
This B-25 flew in the formation.
This was the type of bomber
used by General Jimmy Doolittle,
the MIT grad who led
the first bombing runs
over mainland Japan, and
turned the tide of the war.
What a joy to fly a
B-25 in peacetime,
half a century after the war.
- I just wonder why I had
the absolute best seat.
I was in the
[INAUDIBLE] position,
so I could see everybody around.
I could see the two
fighters off on either side.
And it was just spectacular.
And coming around Boston as they
did, it was just unbelievable.
- This brings it home to you.
If you were in one
of those airplanes
and flying, and feeling like
you're flying this thing
and you're in the turbulent
airwaves behind it, you know,
the air turbulence, being
shot at all at the same time,
it brings it very close to home.
- So much of the technology
developed during World War II
is still in use today.
This DC-3 aircraft served
in both the European
and Mediterranean
theaters in World War II.
On D-Day, it trailed gliders
carrying US servicemen
into battle.
After the war, it became
a corporate aircraft,
and it still is.
This flight through sunny blue
skies over a nation at peace,
over the green patchwork
that is greater
Boston, celebrated technology,
celebrated a school's efforts
toward victory, remembered
a school's gift of its sons
to a nation.
Tom Melville, New
England Cable News.
- Now, Chad Curtis,
Natalie Jacobson,
meteorologist Dick
Albert with weather,
and Mike Lynch on sports.
This is NewsCenter 5 at 6:00.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- But first, we'll tell
you why a bit of history
was soaring over MIT today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
A rare glimpse at history
today in the skies over Boston.
Six World War II
military planes flew
in formation over the MIT
campus just after noon
in recognition of the 50th
anniversary of the end of World
War II.
On the return flight, they did
the traditional missing man
formation, in tribute to
those who died in the war.
Alumni of MIT contributed to
much of the technology used
to win the war.
- It was an absolutely perfect
backdrop for those planes
today.
- It was beautiful.
- Really was.
- Finally the sun was out.
- What a view today,
as several World War II
planes soared across the sky.
At 1,000 feet, this bird's
eye view of Cambridge.
In recognition of
the 50th anniversary
of the end of World War
II, six military planes
took part in a flyby over MIT.
The school
contributed to the war
with technologies such as
radar and long-range weather
forecasting systems.
Also quite a sight for those
of us on the ground looking up.
- All right.
Finally, there was a spectacular
display over the Charles River
today, commemorating
the 50th anniversary
of the end of World War II.
- Several World War
II airplanes flew
past the MIT campus, a
tribute to the MIT technology
that helped win the war.
And as we take a look at
this, we say goodnight.
And have a great
weekend, everybody.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]